I think hacking small businesses is super fun. Every high schooler's dream is to hack
their high school and change their grades, whatever.
We do not endorse this behavior.
Or people know.
That's so true. I totally didn't do that when I was in high school.
Yeah, to not endorse the behavior, good quality stuff. But the reason I think people
want to hack their high school is because you can be the person sitting in the classroom
and maybe the alarm bell goes off and you're sitting there smug like, I did that and nobody
knows that.
Pretty, pretty, pretty, pretty.
Hey everyone, we've all heard of Project Discovery, right? The authors of Nuclei, HTTPX, and countless
other essential security tools.
What you may not have heard of, however, is their conference, Hardly Strictly Security
Conference. This conference is happening April 25th from 8am onward, virtually. And it's featuring
the topic of everything open source security tooling. They'll have speakers from top companies
like Vercel, Datadog, Hashcorp, and Fastly. And it's oriented towards anybody who cares
about open source security tooling, whether you're a bug hunter, a red teamer, security leader, whoever. There should be great content for you at this conference. So if you're interested, head over to nux.gg slash hss24 slash hss24, right? Hardly strictly security, and then 2024. To sign up and register and get in on that conference goodness. All right. With that, back to the show.
All righty, Mr. Sam Curry, we have been prepping, and we have so many stories in the queue here. Welcome to the podcast, man.
Hello, hello. Yeah, thank you for having me.
This is exciting. Sam, you are just kind of like a legendary bug bounty storyteller. So I'm anticipating this podcast being largely me saying, all right, Sam, tell us about the time you got arrested at the airport, or tell us about the time you broke every car in existence. And then sort of hearing those stories and then picking apart some technical details. I think that's how we're going to go today.
But let's start with a story that is not super technical. Tell us about the time you got detained at the airport.
Yeah, sure. So I was just finishing up a trip from US to Japan. I was flying back from Japan and to Washington Dulles Airport. So as I get into the airport, I'm exhausted, 15-hour flight. I'm going through the line, normal check-in, immigration process. But at the very end of the line, they pulled me aside for secondary. They're like, hey,
we just need to talk to you, ask a couple questions. And I haven't traveled too much internationally at that point. So I was like, it's a normal thing, whatever, we'll go. And I realized I'm the only person in the secondary inspection.
And the cop who walks me over there is like super nice. The process is just super, very easy. And they're being super nice to me. We're unloading all my luggage and going through everything. They're asking about my trip. I'm explaining everything about my trip.
And then finally, they asked me for my device. They say like, hey, can we just see your phone and can you unlock it? And it's part of a normal immigration process. They asked for that. I didn't really think anything of it. So I gave the agent my unlocked phone. And then afterwards, I did that. They're like, okay, cool. Now just come over into this room. There's some people who want to talk to you.
And at that point, I'm like, kind of alarm bells. Yeah. And it turns out that there was a IRS CI, which is like their criminal investigation and a department of Homeland Security officer in the room. And they're both sitting across from me. And they said like, hey, you know, Sam, you work here. Here's this.
So they had like knew that you were flying back into the country and they're like, all right, we're going to snag them at the border.
Yeah, it was really interesting because everything was planned and like coordinated before too. Like they had gone. When we arrived in Japan, everybody in our group had like these little bag notices. And I'd never seen them before. I've seen like the normal TSA inspection things, but these were like different notices. And I was like, oh, I guess they changed the thing.
But when I went back and they pulled me into that room, what I realized is that I was under suspicion for like wire fraud and I was being summoned to a grand jury in New York. Yeah. So I immediately asked them, I said like, hey, like, can I have my device back? Because I didn't realize this was like a, you know, targeted thing. And they say like, no, we're actually allowed to keep that because it's a like normal immigration process. So at that point, like I just have to sit there.
What the heck?
It's super tricky too, because even if you're like the most clear conscious person in the world or clear conscience, sorry, your friend could have said something that's like, you know, incriminating. What they'll do is like parallel investigations. So like, even though it was just me under suspicion and it was like a weird narrative and I felt fine about it, it's still like a tricky thing where it's like something on your phone is incriminating.
What did you do? Why were they pulling you over at the border?
Yeah. So what turned out happening immediately after that, they let me have my device back and stuff and they let me through. I contacted my work and my work lawyers got involved. The company I work for is like a Google labs, which is like a cryptocurrency company.
And what ended up happening is through my security work at Google labs, where we were investigating like a phishing website.
I had found a scammer's private key leaked in a JavaScript file. And I take him at scammer's private key and I'd plugged into my MetaMask to see like, are there any recoverable funds?
And by doing that, they thought that I was the scammer.
Oh no. Oh no.
Yeah. It was really tricky too, because it allowed them to do a full subpoena by network. So for instance, they had, you know, my ISP logs, like in a paper thing.
Are you kidding me? Oh my gosh.
Yeah. They read my name, like, or they read my mom's name because my internet was like filling her name. So the whole thing was like very, yeah, you feel like you're, you know, you've like killed somebody or something, but.
It really like shows you how the sausage is made too. Cause now you, you like, you have some insight into what lengths they can go to and what information they can get about you.
Just like without you even knowing, right? Like you, the first that you're hearing of it, they're sitting down with like a stack of paper, like, Hey, here's everything you've been doing for the last few months.
And you're like, Oh, cool. Yeah. What have I been doing for the last couple months? Yeah.
Well, exactly. Yeah. It's very, it feels, it's one of those things you read about. Like I've always had the stance that like, I'll never be important enough for them to like, look at my thing.
But then you realize it could happen to anybody.
Wow, dude. That's crazy. And just to think that like how much of the coordinated effort had to happen too. Cause they're like, you know, they were definitely contact to see or contacting TSA and saying like, okay, here's this guy's picture.
He's coming in on this flight. Like we need you to snag him and we need you to get his phone and then like shove him in this room. And it's like, Oh my gosh. And like, people are, are going there and it's like, Oh man.
Yeah. I do wonder if it was cause it was international and like, they had your passport number, but like they knew it was you, not just some other like Sam Curry.
Yeah. And like, that's why they knew for sure. Like, okay, let's, let's take a look on the way in and on the way out. Yeah. Oh yeah. A hundred percent.
So I guess this, this is a good transition into a different topic, which is a topic that you and I have debated many, many times.
Uh, which is Sam, you do some, you know, for those of you that are listening on the actual audio medium of this podcast, I'm shaking my hand and like, kind of like a iffy sort of way you do some, some borderline things, you know?
Um, and you don't really do it for the bounties. Um, and this is a book bounty podcast. So we normally talk about book bounty, but I'm kind of wondering what your motivation is behind all this and why you're doing that.
Yeah, sure. And for, for those of you who are listening who Justin just made it seem like I'm, you know, killed somebody or something.
No, uh, to clarify a little bit, the, uh, the hacking, the, uh, sort of, I think what Justin's talking about is like, uh,
a lot of the hacking I do is like not necessarily in bounty programs and it's not necessarily scoped in like a specific, like targeted way where it's like, you know, they're inviting you to come look at their stuff. Right.
I like a lot of the hacking I do. And when I originally got into like web security and hacking, it was a lot of like, really like fun kind of curiosity. Right. Um, so a lot of the research we've been doing like recently, um, to, to, to kind of give context to that topic.
Yeah.
When I started bug bounty like eight years ago, right. I was like fresh out of high school and I really wanted to make as much money as I could. Right. Yeah. I grew up like super, like I'm really hungry for, for money. Right. So I'm like, hell yeah. Like $500 bounty there, a thousand dollar bounty there. And it's just like beating, like it's going perfect. Right. And I did that for a while. And I got a job in security and I'm like, you know, the amounts keep getting higher and like, it doesn't like hit the same way.
And then eventually I kind of realized like, you know, like I was, I'm not a really huge spender. I'm very comfortable. Like I think in terms of like my, I think like, I guess I'm trying to describe it, but I think what I'm trying to say.
I know that this is more of a, you know, this is, this strays a little bit more into life philosophy as well, because it's like, you know, it's about this interest that you have now and less about this financial motivation that you had in the beginning. Right.
Exactly. Yeah. Not to, to kind of wrap it down a little bit. The, the hacking we do that we've done recently is like, you have a smaller group of people that I've been working with, like Shabam Shah, like Ian Carroll. And I think like, as a group, we kind of have like this love for life for like hacking stuff. Like it's, it's this deep, like childlike curiosity of like seeing something. And like, again, like the example, like a subway card, you're like, I don't want to pay for the subway. Can I get a million dollar subway card to like go, you know, things like that.
And like, we do it in good faith. And that's when people say like, I'm, you know, doing a gray line or gray area where maybe they're not explicitly inviting us to hack them, but you know, I report them through a security program or security team. The reason I've been able to do that so successfully for like so long, where it's like, I'm not getting in trouble and I'm like helping these organizations is because I think I have like very, very good intent. Like never once have I wanted to exploit something like maliciously. It's always been kind of like found it. It's hilarious. We had a really good time. It's a good story, but it's fixed now.
And that's good. Right. So to talk about like that hacking, like I've kind of fallen. That's, that's how I originally gotten security. And that's kind of how I like keep my flame lit. Right.
It's like sort of interest based hacking rather than like, you know, money oriented or, or even, you know, and, and I guess some of this has to do with, you know, these are good stories as well. And it's, it's fun story to tell and to share that, that light, that, that invigoration, that passion for hacking with others.
And, and, and so the, I guess the reason you're doing this is just because of that, that curiosity. Is that accurate?
Yeah, I think absolutely. I mean, like nowadays it's kind of like a, it blends a little bit more into the normal job space where security is like a normal job that people do.
And like, it's a normal, easy thing that you can kind of get into as a career. But like before, even like, you know, seven or eight years ago, it was a lot blurrier where like hackers, like the whole thing, like every hacker I knew was very like culture oriented, where they just have like this love for hacking, love for security.
They have this ecosystem and it's like this, you know, like the, the introduction song to this podcast, like Whitey Cracker, like as a kid, like I grew up listening to Whitey, I'm 13 years old, 14 years old.
And I'm like, you know, he's like deep in the matrix. It's crazy. Like that world is just like exciting. Right. And I like, as I grew up, that's like my, I still have that world, right? Like it's three in the morning. I'm like deep in something like there's like that really, really deep passion where it's like, you want to do it because you love it. Right.
That's, that's cool. I have to say, you know, a lot of, a lot of people in this industry are green hats, you know, to reference back to YT, um, and, and looking for the money in it.
And, and, and I mean, I'll, I'll say, you know, I do bug bounty full time and I'm not financially independent yet. So, uh, I definitely, that is definitely a motivation for me, but it's definitely cool to see someone a little bit more motivated by the passion for the, the, and letting that be the leading factor. Right.
Like, I, I think for me, it's more of like, I look at a target that I, that I, that has good bounties on it. And then, you know, my passion for hacking comes out against that target because I love the day to day and I love getting in the weeds with it.
And I love reading the JavaScript files and figuring out how stuff's working, but it's still pointed at the top level by that, um, you know, financial incentive.
Um, and then also for me by the safe Harbor incentive as well, which doesn't seem to be as big of a thing for you.
Like, and we've, we've debated this, you know, um, to the end of the, that we can debate this in our little group chats or whatever, but, um, talk to me a little bit about why you feel, why you feel safe hacking all of these targets and, and yeah, let's start there.
Yeah.
Sure.
I think it's maybe the safety is kind of a, I think there's a lack, there's a small lack of safety where as I get older and I think I mature and I kind of settle into like this lifestyle of like less risk that I'm kind of like slowly, like concising down.
But like, for me, I see like hacking, you know, if there's a company that doesn't have a security program, for instance, we looked at casinos recently, I'll give you an example where it was a really bad interaction.
So we were investigating like online gambling and online casinos.
We found this one online casino and there was a specific game in the casino where you're able to replay the request and generate like an unlimited balance.
And we were like, this is hilarious.
We didn't try to withdraw it or anything.
We just reported it immediately.
We're like, Hey guys, like we found this plug.
How many times did you do it, Sam?
And what, well, I think I ended up with a balance of, I ended up with a balance of $3 million in my account, right?
A little excessive.
However, what ended up happening that I didn't realize is that the game providers on the online casinos, like let's say you're a slot company and you make the slot.
But they're like a sub company that sells the slot machine to the gambling website.
Oh, interesting.
Okay.
And what ended up happening?
Yeah.
The gambling website saw the slot machine had generated $3 million and they just cut them off completely.
And they said, we don't want to do business with you anymore because of this vulnerability.
So I got on the phone with this guy in the UK who runs the slot company.
And I'm like, Hey, I just want to report this vulnerability.
And he says, so you're the guy who's committing fraud on our slot machine.
And I'm like, so yeah, at that point, it's like, you know, everything in your head's like, this wasn't my intent, blah, blah, blah.
But they could still see you financially.
And it's like a tricky situation that you have to navigate.
Right.
And of course, the complexities of like UK law versus US and like whether or not you have permission, like it's very complicated.
But like, I think the leading thing is like good intent, but it can, in this case, like stray because it does.
So you can't leave us there, Sam.
What happened, dude?
How did you weasel your way out of this one?
Yeah.
So I weasel my way out by, I, we had like a continued effort to like report.
We reported the bug.
We worked on the fix.
I communicated with the casino.
I said, Hey, I'm a researcher who found this.
We've talked to the company and we kind of meshed it together and things were like good.
And I'm sure you can convey to that company as well.
Like, Hey, you know, the companies that are having their, their products assessed are the ones you want to work with, not the ones that you don't want to work with.
Right.
Because the ones that don't have the product assessed, the bugs are just sitting there waiting for, you know, a malicious hacker to hack them.
Yeah, exactly.
Right.
Like, would you rather have like one example where someone, you know, it's $3 million, but it's never exploited or like thousands of users that are just adding in $100, $200 and then slowly withdrawing money.
It's a really interesting conversation.
I did a training one time.
I was, I worked for a consultancy and during the training, at the end of the training, we, my people who I was working with, the web application security training we did.
He said, let's just like go to this website here to kind of assess the, you know, like look at the security of it.
And it wasn't like a full like test where he was like sending malicious traffic.
But so when the audience was like, Hey, you aren't really allowed to test random websites.
Right.
And then he responds, well, it's like, it's like, it's a personal risk thing where it's like, if you're not doing enough damage or not causing enough noise, like, are you going to get sued?
Probably not.
But it's kind of like your risk profile, right?
Yeah.
I mean, is there, especially for you now established, you know, very publicly as a, you know, white hat ethical security researcher.
I bet that risk is, is probably minimized even more for you than somebody who doesn't have a track record of ethical security research because of the caveats in the, you know, computer fraud and abuse act specifically for good faith security research.
Yeah.
It reminds me of a skit.
Actually, there's a TV show called Nathan for you.
And in the show, he says, he's like, Hey, I want to do this like big public thing.
Great show.
It's a great show.
It's fantastic.
He says like, Hey, I want to do this thing, which is like totally a joke.
I want to make this parody restaurant.
And then he talks to the lawyer and he's like, to make this parody restaurant, what do I have to do?
And the lawyer says, you need to establish yourself as like a comedian or a guy who does like pranks.
So he quickly goes and does like a performance art thing and tries to build a name for himself.
Right.
But I think as a security researcher, like you can Google Sam Curry and it comes up with like the past work.
It's a legitimate person.
Right.
Versus a lot of people I see who try to reach out over email, they'll use their alias.
And it's like hacker 447.
And they're like, I'm not going to give you my real name.
But here's, it's like, I get it.
And I'm, you know, being anonymous, whatever, it's great.
But like you do come off a little more malicious like that.
Absolutely.
Yeah, I think there's definitely something to be said for that established track record.
Yeah.
So when you're picking targets, I know like a lot of it is sort of just like the interest, the love for hacking.
Do you ever sort of like choose not to hack things or to go after certain things?
Like I think there's lots of different levels that you can hack stuff at, right?
So like you can go like to the smallest level where it's like an individual like using a specific instance of a product.
Or you can like go to like the product itself or like the parent company who owns that product.
Or like, you know, you can sort of step up the chain to like larger and larger scopes.
Where do you like to draw that line?
Because I know a lot of people like we have mutual friends who really love hacking small local businesses.
And it's just like they feel, you know, they get a really large amount of impact out of that.
They feel, you know, like that they're creating a lot of good in their community.
Like they have these really great relationships with those small businesses and stuff.
But I would say you probably are hacking mostly small businesses.
You're hacking mostly large businesses.
So what sort of draws you in that direction versus the small business route?
Yeah, so I think like picking targets is really fun because like mostly what I've been looking for recently is like choke points where it's like, for instance, like a single point of failure that has like this cascading effect where it's just like millions of people, right?
I think like hacking small businesses is super fun.
Like it's the every high schooler's dream is like hack their high school and like change their grades, whatever.
We do not endorse this behavior.
That's so true.
But like I totally didn't do that when I was in high school.
So, you know, to not endorse the behavior, good quality stuff.
But like the reason I think people want to hack their high school is because like you can be the person like sitting in the classroom and maybe the alarm bell goes off and you're kind of like sitting there smug like I did that and nobody knows.
Right.
So there's like this, there's this like kind of, you can kind of do that with like small businesses or bigger things.
Like I tend to focus on like big points of failure, like interesting things to me.
So for instance, the research we did with like Nico Spectres with like car security stuff where it's like something I didn't know up until like a few months ago is that you can scan a license plate and it'll give you the Venn number of the car.
Right.
And basically what that means is for every car in the United States, you go from.
Sorry, sorry.
How did you, how did you, how?
Oh, yeah.
So it's public.
You can pay for an API that will basically do this.
No way, really?
Because the, the, yeah, the DMV will sell these records to these like small companies or these like contractors that provide them to like maybe you're a traffic endorsement camera company or something.
Yeah.
So for about like, you know, one and a half cents per API call, you can resolve someone's license plate to the Venn number.
Right.
But so if you think about it, like if, if I want to have fun, like acting stuff and it's like an interesting thing, I'm not, these companies do have safe harbors.
A lot of them.
It's like hilarious to me, like being in line at Starbucks and like the idea, just the idea of it, not actually doing it, but scanning someone's license plate and making their car honk.
Like, it's just hilarious because it's like really fun.
Right.
And that's kind of how.
You know, you see them pull, pull up a little bit before you on the way in, you know, they're ahead of you.
They're walking through the door, you just take a quick picture of their license plate.
When they get in line in front of you, make the larva go off.
They leave line and you just keep going ahead.
Sam, this is so cool, man.
It's a little, yeah.
I mean, like there's, there's kind of, I have to say.
It really is like something I describe it.
Right.
It's like, as an ethical hacker, you do have to kind of like put away the idea of like, you're never actually going to exploit it.
And like your intent is always good.
But like to exchange that, like, I think you do kind of have to like enjoy getting to that point and like kind of dwell on that just a tiny bit.
Like what I'm trying to say is that like, since you never actually crossed that line, I think you kind of have to extract as much fun as possible from like dancing around it a little bit.
Yeah.
If that makes sense.
Well, it's very interesting too, because the attack things, the attack scenarios that you're going after is really there.
What if I were a malicious hacker, this is what I would want to do.
You know, I would want the power to make somebody's alarm go off in their car, you know, in my Starbucks line.
And I would want the power to, you know, unlock locks at a, you know, hotel or something like that.
And, and so all of these targets that you're going after are very like tangible black hat stuff.
Whereas, you know, like my little C-Surf or whatever that I submitted to this, to this company is not something that most black hats are like, you know, chomping at the bit to, to find.
Yeah, sure.
I, there is that big difference, right?
Where like, I think finding the C-Surf can be just as fun and like getting paid for it.
It's like still, it's still really valuable to the team, but like, you know, as like an individual, like let's say you're a homeowner and you have a security system.
And you kind of want to have a clear conscious that like nobody's like looking at you through your camera, right?
So maybe it's a fun thing to do is like hack your home security system, right?
There's a good, there's a guy named NetSpooky who's one of the most talented, like low level engineer people.
It's fantastic, like genuinely great.
But I was having a conversation one day and he told me something that I didn't know, I'd never really thought about it.
He's like, he's like, you know, you can like change your world.
Like if you see something in the world that like you don't like, or it's like you have impact on the world and like you can affect things.
Like it's a really low level point.
That's very cliche, but like very deep, you know, but he, he's like, you know, like if you don't like something in the world, you can change it.
So like the idea of like, you know, I, I'm curious about the security of iPhones because I don't want to get like my iPhone hacked or whatever.
So it's like research iPhone security and then maybe you find something.
But clearly this isn't coming from a place of privacy concerns for you because, you know, you're a pretty public figure.
Yeah.
I, I think it's like a, a lot of it.
So like very like straightforward.
There's like, I kind of dwell on, I think that chaos and the fun and like the kind of the pandemonium of like creating like situations, right.
Where it, it obviously kind of a rush from like, oh, a journalist did a story about a bug you found.
And like, you know, there's people talking about like this, for instance, recently there was a vulnerability.
It was a huge effort by Ian Carroll and Leonard Wouders and their most like talented hardware people.
But like they found this vulnerability where you could unlock any hotel room, right.
Or from a company called Saflock, whose parent company is Dormacaba.
But, but to talk about that, it's kind of funny because it's like, you know, every American's like nightmare for nighttime television is like someone's getting in my hotel room.
So it's hilarious to see like, oh, CBS did a story about this bug.
And like, you know, you're the person who helped with it.
So it's, it's just fun.
That is really cool.
I have to say that is pretty rad.
And, and, and, and just jumping back to the, the online casino thing as well, this has been a pretty good entrance for you to do like pen testing or security consulting for these companies as well.
Right.
Yeah, absolutely.
It's, it's a really good, like it's a sales, it's a salesperson's kind of like dream, right?
Like if I wanted to sell a product to a company, say like a pen test or something, when you report a vulnerability, you're immediately providing value to this company.
Right.
So you say, Hey, I found this bug.
Here's what it is.
Here's how you can fix it.
And they say, thanks.
You know, great to meet you.
You provided value.
Right.
So you have this good relationship with this random company.
It's a really good, like pipeline.
If you did want to sell pen tests.
Right.
Which is like kind of an interesting thing because it, there's a topic I've been really like always curious about where it's like inadvertently, I think I end up in a lot of situations where I'll report a vulnerability to a company and they'll offer me money.
Like not to disclose it.
Right.
That's sketchy.
And even though I never, it's very sketchy because it's like, I never asked this company for money.
I never wanted to like extract money from this company, but I plan on like blogging about it.
And they're saying like, Hey, you know, maybe you don't blog about this and maybe we give you like five grand or something.
And it's like to accept that feels it.
Yeah, exactly.
Like it feels like, so, so like, I think there's a lot of situations that I think it's a really interesting topic of like, you know, maybe you claim you're like a good faith researcher,
but you're hacking all these companies and then you like publicly humiliate the companies and it builds up your reputation.
Yeah.
I think that's like it.
It's a tricky kind of world.
No, it is for sure.
And there's definitely a lot of positive attributes to public disclosure.
But it does, it does.
I mean, I could understand the company's position as well.
And that's an area of like, yeah, we really don't want this coming out under our name.
But it also makes that, that sort of, it helps shift the culture a little bit more towards something that, that makes security look like a good thing rather than a bad thing, which I think is good.
You know?
So if at the end of the day, a company comes out and says, Hey, we were hacked by an ethical hacker.
Here's how we dealt with it.
Here's the disclosure process, that sort of thing.
At the end of the day, if they have a good PR team, that should be spun positively.
You know, we, we were able to secure our devices, you know, in this specific scenario or something like that.
And I think what most people just don't understand about that is that every company has security vulnerabilities.
So the fact that somebody's fixing a security vulnerability doesn't mean that it's bad that they had a security vulnerability in the first place.
It means that there's one less of them, you know?
So I guess I'm sure you have to do some coaching with these companies too on how exactly to portray that to the, to the public.
Yeah.
It's, it's, it's super funny.
Cause like, I think a good parallel there is like the power of marketing to make a company look so big and so secure.
Like the, the mythos of like Apple, you know, you now have this great big company of Apple, but like, then you have this security researcher who's able to like hack Apple.
And it like, instead of, you know, Hey, maybe Apple as a company is like any other company and it has security vulnerabilities.
The media story then becomes like, Oh, this hacker is just so smart that they've hacked Apple.
But it's like, well, no, like it's just any other company.
Right.
Like if that makes sense, basically what I'm trying to say is like, it does, you know, like, yeah.
Yeah.
So do you find that a lot of companies are like, is there any correlation between like size or revenue or anything with like how good their security is?
Or is it pretty much, cause I noticed like when you're picking targets, you really don't like, it never even seems to cross your mind.
Like, Oh, this might be difficult to hack.
You're kind of just like, I want to do this thing on the, like, I want to honk the horn, right?
Whatever it is.
And then you're just like fixated on that and figuring out how to get there.
It doesn't really matter like what the company is or what their infrastructure is.
It's really just like one step towards the goal.
Does it ever like get in your head?
Like, Oh man, this company is like so secure.
I don't think I'm going to be able to hack it or like anything like that.
Yeah.
Sometimes to give an example, there's like a funny enough, I was going through like the San Francisco airport and there was a coffee machine that had like a robot arm.
And it was like a scan on your phone to order a coffee and the robot will make it for you.
And I was like, that's hilarious.
Right.
And it turns out that they deployed this machine inside like Tesla.
Like, so Tesla has one inside their office and it's remotely connected to the internet.
You can push commands to it through some website.
Right.
And I tried super hard to hack this like coffee robot and it couldn't find a single vulnerability.
But then like, as we're going along the airport, I see like, you know, Delta or like an airline.
And no sooner did I find like a critical vulnerability in like an actual airline than like a coffee company.
Yeah.
Right.
And it's like, how do you tell like what's secure?
What's not?
It's really impossible.
Right.
Yeah.
I, I, I've, I've thought a little bit about that.
I was about to ask the same question, Joel.
And it's like, one of the things that I do like about bug bounty in particular though, is that you do get some of the more hardened AppSec targets.
Right.
Most of the, the, the, the very hardened AppSec targets are going to have a bug bounty program because otherwise, how are you, how are you, you know, getting this hardened?
I'd imagine.
And so where does that, where does the actual technical challenge come in for you versus like these goals that you set up for like what you want to accomplish?
Yeah.
So I think that the technical challenge comes in when like the technical challenge for me and like where I really delve into the world of like the technical challenge is like if I have a goal and I can't quite seem to get to the goal and I have to accomplish some hurdle to get there.
Sometimes it's like, I'll discover some new attack method or I'll find like some interesting research because I want some, you know, end goal.
But other times it's like very simple where there's like no research involved.
Everything is very simple.
So for instance, right, like one of the car vulnerabilities we found was like a company called Spurion and there's millions of connected devices that are behind this admin panel.
And to get access to every single one of the devices, it was literally just SQL injection, like admin, quote, space, pound, dash, dash or whatever.
And then you're, and yeah, and it's like, you feel like, one thing that's kind of frustrating for me is like, I've done like, we've done like a lot of really cool blog posts, right?
Where it's cool research, it's interesting.
And then like, maybe I wanted to like blog about like car scooters or something, but like to actually get there, like the actual method is like very simple and you kind of feel like you're cheating people a little bit.
You're like, here's how we did this big thing.
And it's very simple.
And you're like, well, yeah.
Yeah.
And like, you do wish it's, I know exactly what you mean.
Cause you do wish it's like more of a challenge.
Like some of these things are like, oh, this is going to be so hard.
Like I'm going to have to go through all these layers of security and all these things.
And it's literally just like one unauthenticated endpoint.
And you're like, oh, that was really, I mean like, yeah, that's bad, but like, that's so lame.
Like I just, I wish it was more, more fun than that to have to get to here.
Exactly.
Yeah.
There's like no story to it.
It just feels kind of like you're keeping it out a little bit, but yeah, that's kind of thriving in that technicality.
But that's the scary bit though, too, is like, you have these goals, very realistic goals, very black hat e goals, right?
That you would like that any black hat would like to have.
And then they're like textbook SQL injection.
And it's like, oh no.
So, you know, on one hand, it makes for less of a technically interesting story for us that are, you know, often in the weeds and hacking stuff that's really hard and go in there and figure out, okay, you know, it's just like a textbook SQL injection.
But from the story perspective, it actually even makes it a little scarier because it's like, oh, this was a textbook SQL injection.
Somebody, you know, two months into their hacking journey could have found this.
And it does make you understand, like, because we know the vast amount of people that have...
There's a very big difference between the really, really pro security researchers and the amount of people that get far enough to do a textbook SQL injection, right?
Like, there's a way bigger group of people that can do that.
So, there's, by extension, there's a way bigger group of people that could do this from a black hat perspective.
So, it's definitely a little bit scary to see that sort of thing.
I want to take a turn here and talk about this Don't Force Yourself to Become a Bug Bounty Hunter blog that you put out.
I don't even know what one.
This is probably, like, what, five years ago, maybe?
But this is a very interesting blog.
Yeah, four years ago.
Very interesting blog because essentially this is something that you and I kind of discuss on a regular basis.
Just because our personality types are very different in how we approach things.
And essentially what you talked about in this blog was this whole concept of, like, trying to foster the passion for bug bounty versus forcing yourself to be able to do bug bounty.
And I think you can kind of see this come through in your hacking as well because you're spending your time focusing and hacking on things that you're passionate about.
And when you became less passionate about making money, you know, your focus shift from bug bounty to this more, I don't know, mercenary hacking or whatever you want to call this thing, right?
And so, like, what advice do you have for people that are getting into bug bounty and are putting themselves through the challenge of listening to this podcast in fostering that passion and using that as a motivator for their bug bounty experience?
Yeah.
So to talk about that blog a little bit and kind of just, like, the advice is, like, when I wrote that blog, it was at a time where, like, a lot of people were reaching out to me, like, hey, I really want to get in security.
Can you give me tips?
Can you mentor me?
Can you give me these examples?
Like, how do I get started?
What do I read?
What do I do?
And, like, you have, like, kind of this textbook person who they're sitting at their desk.
It's five o'clock.
They just got home from work or school or whatever.
And they're really stressed out because they want to, you know, they see these people, like, finding bugs and, like, how do I get there?
And they're trying to read through and, like, go through these books.
And maybe it's not working super well where they feel like you're kind of in this mindset where you feel like you've got this end goal and you have to, like, really grind to get there.
Maybe there's something in your ethos where it's, like, I need to be, like, military about my study and, like, my work routine and, like, commit to get there.
But when I write about, like, hey, it's, like, don't force yourself to be a bug bounty hunter, it's kind of a preach to people, I think, like, with the same mentality as me.
There are people, for instance, Pete Yorski, who I worked at Shopify.
I don't know if he's still there.
But when he got into bug bounty, he was someone who I think was able to do it really, really, like, military kind of style where he got himself started really quickly, did courses, did trainings, and it worked super well.
Like, Pete became one of the smartest people, like, in bug bounty and, like, in security that I knew.
And he did it through, like, this kind of military training where it was just, like, a lot of, like, intensity.
But me, on the other hand, it was never like that, right?
So when people came to me and were, like, how do I, like, grind?
Like, you grinded, you know?
Like, you have this work ethic.
It's, like, well, no, I don't.
Like, what I did to get, like, bug bounty is, like, I kind of just, like, instead of, like, trying to pick the books to read, you know, I was playing video games.
And I, like, wanted to get rich in the video game.
And, like, that's, you know, like, fostering that, like, flame for me was, like, so much better, right?
And it depends, like, per personality.
I'm not comparing anybody in bug bounty whatsoever to, like, Magnus Carlsen.
But there's a really funny thing in the chess documentary about, like, the world's greatest chess player.
Like, total genius.
Like, fantastic guy.
But when he got into chess, like, his parents realized he loved chess.
And they immediately got on this coach.
And the coach guy, the first one, was, like, you need to read these books and do this.
And it didn't work out.
Like, he immediately became, you know.
But the second coach he got, he looks at Magnus Carlsen and he's, like, let's just step away from it and, like, let him play chess and, like, have a good time with it.
So, like, he's reading, like, you know, like, Donald Duck novels and playing chess at the same time.
And it's, like, he becomes, like, the greatest, like, chess player of all time, right?
Where someone else, like, there are other chess players who are, like, world champions here who have, like, different regiments, right?
Maybe they were born into, you know, very routine-oriented, like, normal stuff.
But I guess what I was trying to get from a blog post is basically, like, if you feel like it's not working well and you feel like there's all this pressure, I've never once found a bug, like, in that pressure.
I've always, like, when I find good bugs, it's, like, relaxed and good, you know.
So maybe don't force yourself.
Yeah, no, that's, that's, that's, I'm sorry, go ahead, Joel.
Yeah.
Well, I was just going to say, like, I definitely felt a lot of this as I progressed throughout my career, both through Bug Bunny and, like, professionally.
Especially with, like, the lack, as I've had both, there's a lack of financial dependence for me for Bug Bunny.
And that's also changed my mindset on it significantly, where when I was first starting Bug Bunny, I was, like, you know, a lot of other people who are starting Bug Bunny, they don't have a lot of money.
It's, like, a really good way to earn money and, like, put your skills to use.
And it's, like, engaging.
But then it shifts, just like any other job, where it becomes work.
And it becomes, like, a thing that you feel like you start to have to do.
And, like, especially when they take it full time, like, you know, I'm sure there are some days you wake up and you don't want to hack, Justin, but you have to, right?
Like, you need to submit a Bug to get, you know, some money today.
Or in three weeks or whatever.
But, you know, and so I think one of the things I really like about how you hack, Sam, is that, like, you, it's not, like, it's almost never about the money, right?
Like, it's about, like, oh, this seems really interesting.
Like, I want to just, like, follow this.
And this is so engaging.
And that's when I find, just like what you said, like, for me, that's how I feel engaged when I'm hacking.
Like, it's not when I'm stressed.
It's not when I'm, like, oh, I need to hack.
Oh, I need to hack.
I need to be doing.
Like, I feel like I have to hack.
No, it's I want to hack.
Like, oh, that's really interesting.
I wonder how that works.
Oh, that's, like, a super interesting thing.
It's not about the bounty.
It's not, oh, do they have a bounty program?
It's like, oh, that would be really cool if I could do XYZ.
Like, I wonder if that's possible.
And I think, like, that natural curiosity is so much better of a driving factor than, like, chasing after money.
Because the money will, like, facilitate things in life.
But it's not going to really necessarily make you happy.
And I would like to know sort of how you balance that.
Because I know you didn't always have a full-time job.
And so hacking a lot of time was a source of money for you.
Did you have to do, like, sort of dual, like, hacking where you're, like, hacking for money and then also hacking for fun?
Or, like, how did you manage that?
Yeah, sure.
So I can actually share, like, my full kind of progression, right?
So, like, my first job, I worked at, like, a fast food restaurant.
So it was very, like, at that time, it's, like, the end of high school.
I'm, like, trying to balance, like, paying certain bills or whatever.
And then I got into Bug Bounty where I'm earning, like, let's say, like, an extra, like, $1,500 a month.
And for me, that was huge.
That was enough to, like, quit my job.
I'm still, like, with my parents this time.
And then after that, I started doing, like, Bug Bounty full-time where I was maybe earning, I think, like, in a year or two, I earned, like, $100,000 USD a year, which is great for, like, Bug Bounty.
And at that point, I was, like, really enthusiastic about it.
But I wanted more stability because I felt kind of stressed.
I was in college, and I was, like, still earning money from Bug Bounty.
But I was, like, this is really unstable.
Life all falls apart.
So then I got a job at HackerOne where I worked as a security analyst or triazer.
So when I was in college, I worked as doing triage for HackerOne.
And I had that kind of consistent income.
But I wasn't doing enough Bug Bounty on the side.
So I was actually making, I think, less.
But it was, like, stable, air quotes, you know?
And then I transitioned.
Sorry, this is, like, the full recap.
But maybe it'll help somebody.
No, this is good.
Because I think this is, I mean, I took a very similar approach.
I think a lot of people do, especially when they're going back and forth between, like, full-time work and Bug Bounty work and all that.
So, yeah, this is awesome.
Yeah, right?
But, yeah, like, the transition part's really good.
But after kind of college, I did, like, a year of college and I stepped away.
And at that point, I wanted to transition into more, like, a real security role.
So I worked at a security consultancy where I was doing 40 hours of pen testing.
It was, like, pen test grind, you know?
That was definitely a grind.
It's probably more than 40 hours.
But it's very routine, like, hacking the same thing.
But it was good money and it was a good salary.
And I didn't feel, like, content at that point because I felt like I was losing potential.
Because, you know, there's, like, Tommy DeVos who's making, like, you know, like, my SSRF was, like, 50K.
I'm like, geez, like, what is going on?
Yeah.
And that was, like, the peak of the Yahoo program, right?
And at that time with the Yahoo program, like, going off, I was, like, I need to step away from consulting.
So I kind of, like, put my two weeks.
I was, like, hey, I really appreciate the opportunity, but I want to do full-time bug bounty.
So then I transitioned to, like, maybe three or four years of, like, full-time hard, like, bug bounty, which was, like, your end time goes up a lot.
And, like, you learn a lot, but it's really stressful.
And at the end of that, at the end of that four or five years was when cryptocurrency stuff started to kind of take off.
And I thought, like, there were so many.
Oh, yeah, go ahead.
I'm wondering why that was stressful and what kind of, is it because the income was inconsistent?
Because for me, one of the things that's been really interesting with full-time bug bounty is you get a big, you know, windfall, essentially, from, you know, a great event or, you know, popping a target or whatever.
And then, you know, the next month comes around and sometimes you still feel like, oh, I need to hack again to pay my bills, but my bills are paid for the next year, you know?
So can you talk a little bit about how that was stressful for you?
Yeah, sure.
I think one big thing for me at the time is, like, I think when I'm hacking or when I'm involved in something, I'm either, like, zero or 100, right?
And one thing that's for me that is, like, I didn't really address until, like, later in my life is I'm a type 1 diabetic, right?
I take, like, insulin every day for, like, meals and stuff.
And I, like, neglected, like, caring for myself pretty much up until I was, like, 20, 22 or something, you know?
So basically my blood sugar, it was, like, four times the normal level it was supposed to be from when I was, like, 12 to, like, 20, right?
And that, like, took, like, yeah, it was really, really bad.
There's probably going to be some, you know, like, I have, like, nerve damage and stuff and things like that.
But, like, when I was, like, doing full-time bug bounty, there were other things, too, that kind of came up where every morning, like, it was kind of funny.
I think the other day I was, like, I was, like, am I allowed to call myself, like, a bug bounty person?
And I realized that, like, pretty much every day for the last, like, seven years, I've consistently just, like, woken up, immediately gone to my computer.
The whole day is at my computer doing security-related stuff, like, every single day.
And a lot of the people I know are the same, right?
But it doesn't really help go towards a balanced lifestyle.
The version of me in high school, I wanted to make a ton of money and I wanted to, like, you know, do these really cool things.
And I really committed to that one bit, right?
But now I have, like, a girlfriend, responsibilities, like, duties.
And I'm doing full-time bug bounty and I can't, like, let that go where it's, like, very stressful because, like, I'm committed to, like, you know, if I don't out-earn myself the month before, I just kind of blow up a little bit.
So that's a really tricky piece, right?
Because it's, like, why do we feel like shit if we have a downtrending month after we just had us, you know, you know, yeah.
Go for it, Joel.
I mean, let me hear your opinion.
It's because your performance is directly based on your personal, you know, like, how good did you do, right?
Did you find the bug?
Did you break through the really hard wall?
And if you don't, then you see it as a personal failure, even though you're dealing in a world where you can be hacking on the coffee machine for three hours and find nothing.
And you can hack on Delta for 30 minutes and find a critical, right?
And the world's just weird and unfair like that.
Totally agree.
Yeah, like, the unfairness I totally agree with.
It's, like, you know, you're looking for, like, ideally, you know, if you, like, lift weight, you're slightly increased your whatever over time.
It's a very consistent good reward.
But, like, you know, like, some people, like, Shubs, like, one of the best hackers ever, has, like, a blog where he's, like, I wasn't able to find bugs for months and it, like, burned me out.
But it's, like, people have down months, like you say.
But, like, mentally being able to separate that is, like, for a lot of us, it's really hard.
Yeah.
Like, after a live hacking event, after a live hacking event, everybody I know was doing full-time bug bounty.
And, like, my whole world was, like, bug bounty, right?
Like, everybody I kind of talked to, bug bounty, bug bounty, bug bounty.
Where now it's, like, you know, I have friends in security who are doing consulting or, like, EDR or, like, these things.
And there's all these different worlds, right?
But at that time, the only thing I cared about is, like, am I going to get MPH?
Like, I got to go for these awards.
Yeah, I definitely feel that.
Yeah.
Gotcha.
It's a different type of goal, you know?
Yeah.
It definitely is.
And there's a lot of aspects to it because the...
And I know for me, just sort of on the flip side, going back to the motivation conversation is, like, for me, my passion...
I have a strong passion for hacking, obviously, but for me, I think the dopamine payout or whatever is oriented a little bit more towards success as a generic entity rather than hacking in general.
You know?
Like, I love the process of hacking, but my payoff comes from succeeding in some way, right?
So that's why, like, for bug bounty, that's why I can pick a target and I can say, okay, my goal is...
It's to, you know, hack this target or whatever and make this money or whatever.
And it's not...
And goal-oriented hacking is really helpful.
We've talked about that on the pod.
It's super invigorating when you actually pop the goal of what you want to do.
But I think for me, it's more of a success-oriented thing.
And that's why I have a little bit more, I think, sustainability than most people in bug bounty.
Because it's like, okay, let me just set these arbitrary little goalposts, right?
Okay, I want to get this extra gadget.
And we've talked about this as well.
It's like, you got to recognize little pieces of success on the way with hacking because sometimes you are going to slam your head against the wall and you're not going to get anywhere.
But if you recognize, oh, hey, there's a gadget that allows me to do a path traversal in an OAuth flow, even though I don't know how to leak the code, I can lend it on any page in the domain, right?
That gadget alone should be a little bit of a payoff for you from a motivation perspective.
And keeping those up, I think, really, that's kind of where my motivation comes from in these sort of scenarios, which is pretty different.
And the long-time bug bounty flow is really tricky to stay healthy throughout that whole thing.
And you mentioned, I think, in that blog post that we were talking about, the don't force yourself to be a bug bounty hunter, that you have dealt with burnout along the way.
And I'm wondering how you deal with that and how – because four years as a full-time bug bounty hunter is a long stint.
So how did you get over those and how did you return to hacking when you were kind of burnt?
Yeah.
And also, maybe that'll cycle back in because I know we kind of paused your story as you were going through sort of how you got to where you were.
So I'm also curious how that played in.
Oh, yeah, absolutely.
I think four years is a long stint for anything, I think, too.
And one big part of that is you're learning the whole rest of your life.
I'm talking to people who are having kids.
They're getting married.
And there's, like, so much, like, you're trying to – so maybe, like, you've got your – I mean, it's just so much you're trying to process, right?
But to go to the bug bounty part where it's, like, burnout can be really tough where, I mean, some of seriously, like, maybe –
I think a year and a half ago, I probably had, like, the worst year of my life because I was removed from – I kind of removed myself from bug bounty.
I'll talk more about that.
And I didn't really have any metric to kind of feel successful or, like, anything to tie my success to or happiness to.
And I just felt very stagnant.
And the reason for Bing was to go all the way back to the four years of bug bounty.
It had its highs and lows, like, its rollercoaster like everything else, you know.
One of the events, like, I ended up, like, working with, like, Doggy G.
We got, like, first and second place.
I was really happy with.
And that's, like, a really high moment for me is, like, being able to get the awards and, like, going out on stage.
And it's, like, you've done a really good job.
You feel great.
But then the other months where it's, like, you don't find anything, it's, you know.
But, like, dealing with that is super tricky.
And it's, like, a life thing, I think, where you're trying to learn how to deal with that.
But what ended up helping me was transitioning to starting a consultancy, which is what kind of I did after that, where instead of doing bug bounty, I wanted to get kind of more involved in the pen test world.
And I kind of started the story a little bit.
But at that time, we were auditing a lot of, like, cryptocurrency stuff because there's all these crypto bug bounty programs.
And we realized that they didn't really have a lot of web security.
So we started doing web consulting for, like, you know, these big exchanges like Bitfinex or Coinbase or, like, OpenSea, things like that, right?
And we, me, Brett Beerhaus, Mike Robert, we have this small team of people who built this company out over a little bit over a year, right?
And it was really, really fun where you started this big process where you've got your, like, statement of work, these documents, everything's signed up, and you're getting clients and stuff.
And you have that growth, right?
So it was a year of building something great and, like, you're really happy about it.
But what ended up happening was, like, we, one of our customers that we worked really closely with, they actually acquired the company.
And we went over to work as employees.
And at that point in time, like, it was really great and we were doing a lot of work, but it slowly kind of into less work and less work.
And I wasn't really, I was working in a private company now, and there wasn't a lot of security people.
And the work we were doing, like, wasn't, I didn't really feel like I was, like, maybe doing the same level of work I was doing before.
And it kind of turned into just not really having any positive feedback, right?
And that year of my life, I think, was, like, really, not knowing how to, like, manage that was really, really hard.
But, yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, it sounds like you were kind of in a bit of a flux where it's, like, you know, you just come off this sort of high intensity push for the last couple years of just, like, nonstop grind.
And then you suddenly fell into this very stable situation.
And, like, almost, like, too stable, where it's, like, there's no, like, where's the excitement?
Like, there's nothing really, like, it's so day in, day out, just, like, come to work, leave work, come to work, leave work.
Like, you know, and there's, it's just, like, not very fulfilling.
And is that sort of the point where you started doing the big target hacking?
Or, like, were you already kind of doing a little bit of that and you were, like, let's get back to that?
Yeah.
So I think I was doing a little bit of that.
But I kind of transitioned to it a lot harder at the end of it.
Because it really does suck.
Because bug bounty specifically, too, is, like, you work, you put in the hours, you get a bounty.
Like, it's a very, the cycle is there, right?
But with a salary, it's just so disconnected of, like, do you do extra work this month, no work this month?
And it shifts a lot.
Like, realistically, like, it's going to shift a lot, right?
But you still get that consistent paycheck every month.
And then your brain kind of stops.
It, like, removes that association you had before of, like, time, effort, money, right?
So, like.
So true.
Yeah.
It really sucks.
And at that point, yeah, I kind of was, like, I want to do more of what I love that has, like, results and stuff, right?
Like, working.
The Shubs, I think, too, kind of felt the same way.
And I had a long conversation about it where he has done, like, so much security work and, like, provided, like, so much value and done bug bounty so much.
But, like, at the end of the day, he wanted to do, like, high-impact vulnerability research.
So we kind of worked together on that.
And that changed a lot, right?
Yeah.
So I will say I noticed that you do a lot of collaboration and stuff with other hackers.
Oftentimes, a lot of the same hackers.
But what has sort of led you to, like, what, I know a lot of this stuff, like, you'll just, like, be in one of our group chats.
And it'll be, like, four in the morning.
And you'll just post, I just found some crazy vulnerability, like, X, Y, Z.
And it's just like, okay, I'm going to go to sleep now.
You're like, oh, okay, that's pretty wild.
But that's not all the time.
Like, I know sometimes you do sort of fall off into your little hacking cave.
And you're there secluded doing your own thing.
But other times, there's, like, this secret sort of huge force of hackers behind a lot of the work that's being done of really, really talented people working together to sort of exploit large systems at scale.
I like to think of it sort of as putting together, like, an A-team where you're, like, you know, all these action movies are always, like, you get the hacker and the tech guy and the driver and the gun guy.
Like, it's kind of like that when you're, like, building together this team.
But you know so many people.
We all know so many people that are really, really good at these things.
How do you, you know, pull your team together?
How are you deciding, you know, who you want to work on stuff?
Like, when to reach out for help and not just do something yourself?
Because it's not like there's a bounty here.
It's not like you're at risk of, you know, duping or anything like that.
Like, you're very deep into these systems most times to the point that nobody else is.
So it's not really, like, there's a pressure thing.
What sort of, what's the thought process when you start to reach out and build, like, pull more people into these projects?
A lot of times, like, the initial thing for me is, like, a specific question, right?
So, for instance, like, Joel, you're one of the greatest, like, mobile hackers.
Like, I know nothing compared to you, for instance.
So, like, whenever, like, something mobile-related that's, like, confusing or is, like, really difficult to kind of approach, like, I'll often just, like, reach out to you and, like, hit you up.
And then, you know, at that point, you're, like, in Corellia making a script.
And then, like, it's this collaborative process where now you're involved because you've done the thing and you're invested.
You're, like, okay, what's going on?
And then maybe you want to keep working on it.
I nagged a lot.
Like, for the Apple research, like, Brett, when I first started it, it was just me and I was doing it.
And I was sending everything to Brett.
He must have gotten, like, he's got kids.
He's got a wife.
It's dinner time.
His phone's probably blown up.
I'm like, Ziya, dude, like, please, like, please hop on this.
Like, and he eventually did, right?
And then he's, like, what's all the fuss about?
And he joins in.
He's, like, oh, this is actually interesting.
So I think, like, I don't know.
I don't have, like, there's no elitist, like, there's, like, this concept of, like, a hacker group or whatever where, like, you used to have, like, this hacker name and, like, this big, you know, be, like, Team Poison or something.
You've got, like, the eight members.
And it's, like, this kind of elite organization or something.
But for bug bounty stuff, it's just, like, hey, I'm going to spam you with stuff.
And you can help if you want to.
And then maybe you, like, add one thing and add another thing.
And, like, we build the full picture.
And then, like, people get credited and stuff, right?
Yeah.
So, yeah.
That's good.
No, that's good.
I mean, I think what I see especially is everybody has these skill sets.
It's just like you said, like, I'm good at mobile.
So, if somebody needs to unpin an app instead of spending four hours, like, trying to break their head through their computer screens to, like, figure out how that works, they just send me a message.
And I'm, like, in 30 minutes, I'm, like, okay, here you go.
All done.
And, like, that sort of outsourcing of work can be so useful when you're attacking these big targets because it's just, like, lots of different skill sets, right?
I think that's one of the really awesome things I've noticed as you attack targets across all spectrums of things, whether it's airlines, whether it's hotel key cards, whether it's ISPs, TLDs, Starbucks, whatever it is, right?
Like, they're all using different technologies.
They're all using different, you know, setups and configurations.
And the method of attack can be different a lot of the time.
But you have a really good way of identifying, like, hey, you're good at this thing.
Like, help me with this.
And then not only that, but you, like, pick up that skill yourself really well.
And then you're able to sort of, like, foster it and use it later.
And I think it's really amazing to just sort of see the research as it goes.
I did want you to talk a little bit about Hack Compute, actually, because as we're talking about sort of these, like, big hacking projects and stuff, I know that this is something that you and Shubs and a couple other people have been working on sort of maybe quietly-ish behind the scenes.
But, yeah, can you just tell a little bit about what that is and everything?
Yeah, sure. So, Hack Compute is kind of like this fun group we put together where it's, like, we wanted to have, like, this idea of, like, old-school style zine publication where it's, like, fun hacking research that's maybe not, you know, either bug bounty.
It doesn't end in, like, oh, and then we got 20,000 to do it.
It's mostly just kind of fun research, right?
And the idea for it originally is that it would kind of exist as, like, this kind of, like, nameless.
Each blog post would have a different group of collaborators, and each post is just, you know.
And then we would do cool, like, high-impact research or things that were interesting to the people who wanted to contribute to it.
And the way it came about was because when we did the car hacking research a few years ago, I, like, it was kind of, like, me and a few people originally who were pushing towards, like, let's do car hacking.
And it had this big group chat, and there's a lot of people involved.
But the blog actually got, ended up getting published on samcury.net, my domain.
And even though, like, the names were listed as collaborators, I still, like, there's this, like, kind of small tension of, like, hey, like, we all did this work, but it's hosted on samcury.net.
And also, like, I just feel super guilty about it because it's, like, when people go to see the blog post, it's on samcury.net.
Like, you know, it's, like, the Facebook, like, a Mark Zuckerberg production, whatever.
And I just, like, it doesn't feel good because you feel like you're stealing people's credit.
Right.
And the idea for HackCompute is, like, this idea where it's, like, intentionally collaborative, where it's behind a name.
And that's kind of, like, the origin of it.
Right.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
That makes a lot of sense.
And that way, you know, it can be, and that way lots of different hackers can contribute it to it.
And it can sort of just be a hub for really awesome hacking achievements.
Definitely excited to see where that goes.
And if I ever pop anything not bounty-related, I'll let you know and we can see if we can put it up there.
Please.
Yeah, we love that.
Cool.
Okay.
I did want to talk about some technical stuff, too.
Hold on.
I'm sorry.
Before we get, because I do as well, but I actually wanted to hit one more non-technical topic before we transition.
Is that fine?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Go for it.
And then we'll transition into some hacking stories and getting the technical content.
We have our little doc over here.
And it says, one of the things you wrote down here, are we really even solving problems here with bug bounty?
And I think this is a really interesting question and one that I kind of want to flesh out a little bit with you.
Like, what are your thoughts on the efficacy of bug bounty with regards to security as a whole?
Yeah, let's leave it at that.
Yeah, absolutely.
So the conversation around, like, is bug bounty solving the issues?
Like, I think you could approach it at every angle and pick the supporting evidence and prove every point.
So, for instance, I could say, like, bug bounty isn't solving any problems because your C-Surf isn't fixing any real bug that a nation state.
And someone's always going to social engineer and blah, blah, blah.
And it's like, but on the other hand, it's like bug bounty has, like, created this, like, culture of, like, app sec focused, like, web security, like, heavy.
Like, it's kind of brought itself, like, there's these old school hackers who are doing, like, internals and windows.
And, like, they saw web security as, like, this kind of lame, like, cross-side scripting.
It's like, who cares?
But, like, nowadays, like, everything is web.
Like, if you wanted to pick a single category of research to get into where you have the most impact and most, you know, expandability, it's, like, web security.
Right?
And I think bug bounty has, like, everybody having bug bounty programs.
Like, pretty much every company has a bug bounty program now or at least a security contact.
Right?
Okay.
All right.
With that caveat, I'll let you off.
There's still so many programs that don't pay for bounties, which is really crazy to me.
But, yeah, there's definitely been a big expansion of, like, security.txt and that sort of thing in the past couple years.
Yeah.
I'll even name drop.
Like, Codflare.
Like, 5K max.
Like, you run the internet, dude.
Like, you've got, like, 80% of every website.
It's, like, please, you know, like, increase your bounties because nobody's, like, hacking on it for money because you're...
With that big of a target.
Exactly, right?
Like, I totally agree that, like, some companies, like, 100%, but, like, the difference between, like, you know, and it's such a...
I'm not that old, but even, like, five years ago or six years ago is, like, you've got, like, Yahoo and, like, the big companies.
And, like, companies, like, big, big companies are being brought and, like, doing bug bounty, right?
So with the question of, like, are we even solving stuff, I think that, like, AppSec and, like, patching out these, like, single issues is contributing to this big kind of security culture and knowledge base that is, like, really, really affecting change and, like, security stuff.
And you're seeing a lot of pushes now from, for instance, like, Jack Cable was a very prolific bug bounty hunter and he got involved in, like, CISA and, like, U.S. government stuff.
And he's helping with this push towards, like, secure code by design, right?
Which is a huge, really great effort of, like, you know, can we fix...
Can we take what we've made, adjust it a little bit and fix it, like, fundamentally?
And I think that's, like, a really great push.
But that's kind of my conversation about that and how I feel.
So, go ahead.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
Well, I would say definitely, like, from a program side and, like, a security team side, you know, I think most companies should have some sort of at least a security contact, but maybe a bug bounty program as well.
Like, all the bug bounty program really does is, like, offer people an incentive as well, right?
Like, if you want people to come and hack on your company and find vulnerabilities externally, then you can offer money for that and you can put money where your mouth is.
But if you just want a place for people to be able to reach out, you can do that without a cost.
I think it's important that, like, you know, no products is going to be free of vulnerabilities, right?
And, like, eventually there's going to be some hacker who's going to want something from, like, your company and they're going to try and find some way to do that.
And if you have some ethical way for them to reach out, that's fine.
But, like, it's not an end-all-be-all solution.
It's not a silver bullet.
It doesn't actually create, like, security in a sense.
Like, it's just part of the, it's like what you said.
It's like it all flows into, like, what is security as a whole?
Like, what's your security posture?
And, like, having some way for external researchers, ethical or bug bounty or whatever, to reach out is just part of that posture.
But it's not like, oh, we have a bug bounty program now.
Like, thankfully, all the hackers are now going to submit their vulnerabilities to us.
And we'll never, like, fire all those AppSec engineers.
We just need one guy to triage.
Like, that's, you know, I think that's a really common misconception that a lot of companies think is like, oh, once they spin up a bug bounty program, now they're secured on all fronts.
And it's like, all you've done is created a doorway or, like, a mailbox for people to, like, insert letters.
But people could just, like, ignore that and just walk past it and not give you the letter or, like, post it on a blog or, like, reach out via email or, like, all these other ways.
So I think, you know, it's a good, yeah, maybe, like, hackcompete.com or something.
I don't know.
Yeah, but no, I totally agree.
Like, I think it's definitely, like, just a little piece.
And it does solve, like, some things for sure.
Like, there are absolutely things that get caught through bug bounty that wouldn't get caught otherwise.
But it's such, like, a niche almost, right?
It's not pen testing.
It's not internal security.
It's bug.
It's, like, its own little part of the pie chart.
There's definitely an order of operations there, too.
Like, I feel like you should not have a bug bounty program if you don't have 2FA enabled, you know, or if you don't have, like, a hard bug.
Or something like that.
Because at the end of the day, most of the attacks are occurring from phishing and stuff like that.
But one other thing, and I've been kind of toying around with this in my head for the past couple of years of, like, okay, you know, if an attacker is really going to go in, they're going to go in by this pathway, right?
But at the end of the day, if you have a bug that is just going to let you, let's just say, theoretically, you had a zero-day RC on Nginx, right?
Like, you're always going to use that.
Like, you're not going to go fish somebody if you've got a way in where you have no interaction with any other people.
Especially when these hackers are spending, especially the highly technical ones, are spending a lot of time with the computer, you know?
And less time, you know, deceiving people and, you know, building those skills required to do that.
So I definitely think there's two sides of the coin.
And I definitely think there is a lot of risk from an AppSec perspective.
And I think the biggest risk, though, that I think BugMount really helps absolve is getting users very, very deep into your application where actual, you're getting hackers really deep into your application where the users are.
And then getting trained security eyes on that, incentivized trained security eyes on that, right?
Because, you know, all it takes is one user that says, oh, you know, in this weird, obscure functionality where, you know, deep, deep, deep, deep, deep in the application where the URL says, oh, you know, user ID equals one, two, three.
Look what happens if I change that to a four?
And then now your database is gone, right?
And so getting deep into that and getting hackers that deep will help prevent those very obvious, you know, vulnerabilities, as well as secure some of those more APT type threats.
I mean, are you with me on that?
I mean.
Right.
Yeah.
100%.
I mean, like the idea of like an exploitable CVE that comes out and then like you have like 20,000 researchers who immediately spray it on every organization like that has it reduces the time to fix, I think, significantly.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
I love that it how it highlights like key areas that need fixing, right?
Like systemic things.
Like if you see researchers like every time an XSS comes in, like they're getting an ATO because your cookies are not properly secured.
Or your auth token is stored in a bad place.
Like that's a really easy business justification to be like, hey, we have external security researchers who are finding this problem.
We need to fix this like ASAP.
Right.
And like there's like a one to one correlation there.
But it's not always that.
Like it's like sometimes it'll be like a broken social media link and you're like, how do I bring this to my engineering team?
And be like, hey, guys, the Twitter link is broken.
They're like, what is security?
Oh, God.
Yeah.
No, that is a pain.
Hey, guys, real quick.
I just wanted to give a shout to the hacker content team.
They have been absolutely killing it the past couple months, taking the content from the podcast and condensing it down into consumable social media posts, whether it be shorts or text posts or whatever.
They've been rocking it.
So I just wanted to give them a shout out and let you know that they do all sorts of cybersecurity content as well as social media management.
They do technical blogs.
They do comprehensive social media management.
So if your organization could benefit from any of those types of services, make sure you head over to hackercontent.com, drop them a line and mention the podcast when you do to get your first month of cybersecurity content marketing services for free.
All right.
That's it.
Let's get back to the pod.
All right.
So with that, let's let's let's set those those.
um, stories and more philosophical stuff aside and let's go deep into some some technical stuff.
Sound good?
All right.
Sure.
Cool.
So Sam, you have so much research online, so many stories, um, so many cool things that, uh, we need to unpack here.
But one of the things you are most well known for is secondary context bugs.
Um, I don't know.
Did you like my first exposure to secondary context was you?
Uh, did you, did you coin that term?
I did.
Yes.
It was funny.
It's, I appreciate it.
Yeah.
It's funny seeing that term like used.
I'm like, Oh my God.
Someone's actually using that word.
I just put those two things together.
That's like a talk title.
That's clutch, man.
But it, it, it, I mean, obviously I'm sure some OG, you know, on some blog back in like, you know, 28, well, you know, 20, 28, 28, 28, 2008.
Yeah.
In the future.
There you go.
No, um, you know, way back wrote something about it, but, uh, you know, that blog or that talk that you did on secondary context stuff was my first exposure to that.
Um, and, and I think it, it, it really made it more, uh, widely recognized in the industry.
Um, and we have a cool, cool bug.
We can talk about that with the Starbucks bug.
Um, and that's on simcurry.net as well.
Uh, that you guys can go read about, but talk to me about when you started realizing secondary context bugs were a thing and how you started working through that whole concept.
Right.
Yeah.
So my initial exposure to like secondary context bugs was on, uh, Yahoo's luminate, which was like Yahoo's small business platform for like deploying websites and stuff.
And what I realized was that, uh, I originally thought it was like path, like file path traversal.
Right.
Because I was like able to traverse and like add directories and I'd been spending so long on this one app and I was just like getting, and I eventually started testing for it.
And I'm like, Oh my God, there's file path traversal.
And even in, it's funny too, cause I blogged about it.
And even in the blog post, I refer to it as like, I remember this.
Local file.
I remember this.
So this was not a file path traversal.
Yeah.
It was not.
It was actually HB path traversal.
And, uh, it was actually HB path traversal.
But even at the time, like, I'm like, I guess the X password file just didn't exist.
And it's like, no, that's just not, that's not what was happening.
Um, so with that kind of exposure to it, uh, I started looking for similar stuff in more and more places.
And I eventually realized that like the internet was slowly being built towards this like interesting, like network model where like, oh, you want to serve a CDN from like www.yahoo.com where like you want to serve images, but you don't have to like, you've got this very complicated configuration of like.
Like proxy rules and different passes.
So maybe that, you know, slash images, instead of being like a folder on like one box because
of like load balance, how crazy that would be if it was just all served from the same box.
Like now the slash images route is being proxied to like some internal server for a CDN.
Right.
That's interesting.
Do you think this is a function of needing to do load balancing more effectively?
I think it's a mix of things, right?
I think that, um, if you're a team who you have like, you know, maybe a static blog, but
at the same time, like you have a authentication functionality on your static blog and the team
who deploys, you know, you've got like DevOps team one, DevOps team two, and then like you
have to kind of merge them together.
Sometimes the easiest way to like differentiate routes and folders and things, I think is by
adding that reverse proxy and then separating the services into two.
Um, yeah, so that's probably the biggest thing that I've seen from like the engineering side
is it's the service, like that service aspect.
A lot of people don't think about this because they're not in engineering org, but for engineering
orgs, like they split up functionality into services, right?
And services are separately deployed.
And in order for these things to interact with each other, instead of having just one
giant application that's handling everything from one place that can interact internally
with everything itself, it has to make some sort of call.
Whether that's like gRPC or Kafka or whatever, like, and a lot of times it's just HTTP.
They build an HTTP client, like for that service that just like calls internal endpoints on
that other service on, you know, their internal network and it passes data back and forth.
And it's a lot, you know, it's a lot more simple than people would think where they're like,
oh, like, you know, they must have, their load balance, it's like, no, they, there's two separate
services and they have to talk to each other somehow.
And they just did that with an HTTP request and they did it really, really quickly and effectively
in an insecure way.
And that's where things are starting to fall apart.
Right.
Yeah, exactly.
And like, even external services too, like APIs, like maybe you've got like a maps plugin,
like you want to serve that data and you pass in a path that goes to like Google maps API.
And like, it's very, very interesting how like complicated it goes.
I think one of the reasons like this kind of research kind of came about, there's different
people who had worked on like similar things in the past.
There's really excellent blog posts, like Franz Rosen.
He, he should have been like, he should be the originator.
His work with like Matias and others, like, I think probably even a few years before that
talk and I even messaged him when I gave a talk.
I said like, I feel like this is similar to a lot of work that you've done in the past.
And I was like, if there's anything here, like I'm going to make sure to credit you for a lot
of this.
I want to make sure I'm not like stepping on your toes a little bit, but I wanted to say like
the, the way that, the way that I totally lost my train of thought, but maybe I can,
maybe I can redirect you.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
That's fine.
The, the, so as you're starting to develop this, this understanding of essentially modern
web architecture where these reverse proxies are in, are in place like that.
Um, and the, the tricky part for me still lies in where does the authentication live?
Because there's, there's a lot of, there's a lot of, uh, secondary context,
past traversals all over the place, but the backend server is also using auth and it's just like,
okay, well I can hit a different end point, you know?
And sometimes you can do weird stuff with that.
Like, like C-surf or like, um, you know, some sort of, um, method confusion and that sort of thing.
But, uh, the majority of the time that have understanding that auth piece is really, is really pivotal.
Right.
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
I mean, the auth component is so important to everything because like,
if you're a, like a lot of structures, for instance, uh, we saw this a lot in the car hacking where,
as an example, like you have Sirius XM at the top where there's all these different vehicle
brands beneath it, like Ford, you know, whatever.
But the Sirius XM service is like the authenticated one.
So each of those car companies has like an API key that they use globally.
So it's like, once you, if you can leak that key, change the context between like one user with access
to one thing.
And then like you leak the key and then you can talk to that service and you get access to that
backend service.
Yeah, exactly.
Right.
So one example there is like, you know, maybe you're fuzzing for, you know, secondary context
stuff and you throw in like a new line character for a URI parameter instead of like your account
ID, maybe you do one, two, three percent zero D. And then you get a stack trace back where it's like,
the API call to internal.company.com question mark API key equals.
And you're like, aha, I see the API key.
You take that.
And then you're like, Hey team, this is allowing me to access anybody's stuff.
So you give it to them, right?
But like you said, the authentic, yeah, it's tricky to figure out.
Maybe, yeah, maybe, maybe it is, but, you know, doing some hacking on the program recently.
And I don't know if you can disclose their bugs, but there's a lot of similar stuff,
like there, right?
Mm, with the secondary context stuff?
Yeah, it's like, yeah, there's tons of, a lot of the, for instance, like a lot of people hunt
for actuators like really heavily. And like, when you start exploring like actuator secondary context
stuff, it's really fun because it's like, you know, in some JavaScript file somewhere, there's
like this route, which is a reverse proxy. Maybe it's like API GW dash, you know, internal slash or
something. Then you hit that route. And then that's where you append your actuator ends or like dot,
dot, semi colon slash actuator ends. And then like, it lets you kind of hunt more thoroughly, I guess.
So you're hitting, I guess in this scenario, you're hitting dev, API, API dev endpoints using this, this
new secondary context sort of path traversal. So going through the front end, then traversing on the
back end, hitting these actuator endpoints, which wouldn't be exposed publicly because of probably path
limitations, um, through the reverse proxy. And, and then like, are you normally hunting for things
where it's going to dump the full response back to you without any modification? Or are you, you know,
trying to hit these things blind? Because a lot of times there's a parsing of the response from that
backend API. And then that, that kind of hex up your, your visibility into the backend, right?
Right. Yeah. The having a response is beautiful. It makes you so happy when you see that
HP response leaked back to you, you feel amazing. But a lot of times it is blind, right? And I was
with another researcher, Nathaniel. Yeah.
It really is. Um, it's like a, I would say too, like to finish that bit, like a Nathaniel Latimer,
Donut. Yeah.
Um, I was with him on a trip and I like stormed into his hotel room, like manically with my laptop.
I'm like, if I do dot, dot slash ABC, it doesn't do anything. But if you do dot slash XYZ, it does this
thing, but like, I can't reproduce it on this one. And like, he, he's looking at me. I've sat there
for six hours trying to figure it out. And he's like, this guy, like, what is he talking about?
Like it's absurd because there are so many conditionals that relate to like the, uh,
you know, like you're trying to explain to your friend, you're like, if I do a pound sign,
it does this behavior. And if I do an ampersand, it's this behavior. And like, you have to like,
really build out this like brain map for each individual case. Right. I think the most complicated,
like secondary context bug I had was like this stored, uh, you would add a value to a database
with like an amp sign and like change the print, you change the format from XML to JSON.
Yeah. And then like on another endpoint, you'd call it and you'd get retrieved it.
Like, and it was just like, so it's like a stored secondary content. I've never even thought about
a stored secondary context. Yeah. Uh, logically, a lot of times, uh, it can be,
uh, some things I think you can look for there if it's like external services, like external APIs that,
you know, for instance, uh, you know, are, are they leveraging some third party API that has an API key
or like, or is there one you've already identified that's like, you can kind of add onto, um, but
they're so case by case, right? Like one service has like one behavior and you have, you have to build
those mind maps, I guess. Yeah. And when you're talking about the external services, it makes me,
it reminds me of the Starbucks bug. And just to give a quick overview of this, um, like essentially
what in this scenario, we actually had access to the full response, right. That was coming back.
And, and we were able to, on that one, we were able to path traverse back on, on the Starbucks API
and hit, it was, it was a third party, right? It was Microsoft. Was it graph?
Yeah. It was a Microsoft graph search. I think it was like, uh, they had like a,
I don't know if it was a third party service or it was a utility they had, but it was connected to
their core, their core Starbucks, a hundred million user records was it was connected to.
Yeah. And so essentially like we were working on this together and what amazed me when we were
working on this together was one that you identified one that leaked the full response,
which allowed us to get so much more, I just did data back. But, um, uh, but for two,
you were able to brute force these paths along the way. And I just, I don't know, man, I don't know.
Maybe it's just because I don't do a lot of brute forcing as a part of my methodology,
but it's just, that's just some, and Franz Franz does it even weirder. I mean, Franz
brute forces it as well, but Franz also just has like this sixth sense of like, you know what I bet
customer is before this. And it's like, and then he'll guess because we were working on this target
and it was like, it was, we weren't allowed to brute force. They said explicitly, literally no
brute force. Please do not brute force it. Okay. And so we're like, we need to brute force it. Cause
how are we going to figure out the paths, you know, that we're traversing and Franz just guessed four
paths deep. And I'm like, you've got to be kidding me, man. Um, so I guess for this,
in your experience with the brute forcing, what is your approach to that? What word lists are you
using? Are you generating custom things? You know, is it just something I've got to start doing it that
I'm not doing? Yeah. I mean, a really, a really simple list I like to use, um, it's in burp by default,
but it's like server side variable names and it's just like, you know, path parameter. Yeah.
Exili, uh, Mike Robert showed me this, like he uses it from time to time for like parameters and
stuff. But I think if you go to the simple list, it's like server side variable names, but, uh,
the thought process for trying to brute force the paths or guess the paths is like,
one, it lets you confirm that like, you're not just traversing to like the same request you're on.
Cause a lot of the times what will happen is like, you think you're traversing, but in reality,
it's like a normal side, like API request where it's being condensed down to the normal request.
So you're actually just calling yourself. So, um, but yeah, it's very, you're like,
Oh, I'm just, you know, you like spam so I'm out and you're like, do your messages. Like,
nevermind, ignore me. Um, but the, uh, but brute forcing the paths is really fun because like,
you know, you can kind of guess like, for instance, if it's Franz, I've mispronounced his name for 10
years, you know, so I apologize. Um, but he, he would doing a customer like makes a lot of sense where
you can kind of guess the format ish like D one, you know, V two V three, whatever,
but building it out. Um, I wish there was more general tips, but it really is case by case basis.
You know, are they using camel case, lowercase, upper, are they separating the front end,
like paths for that to, to determine that information or you, cause I guess at some point
it's getting proxied back through. So maybe they're using similar name conventions on the back end as
well. Yeah. That's, that's one thing that, uh, you can kind of pick up on is like on the front end,
if they refer to your account as like account underscore ID or something like that, you know,
those variable names that are like normal, you can kind of like interplace those. Um,
most of the time I'll just send it through if there's no rate limiting, I have like a massive
word list that Chubbs gave me that is like 500,000. They're really good. Yeah. Um,
so, so I did want to ask, um, you mentioned that you have these mind maps that you do. Um,
can you maybe talk a little bit about what that means to you and sort of like how that plays into
any note taking you do? And like, cause again, like you typically are hacking on very large scale targets
and these are ongoing engagements for weeks, months at a time. Um, and so there's a lot of
information, a lot of data, a lot of connecting parts together. And even on single, like small
scope programs that exist and that can be hard to track. We've talked a lot about note taking and all
that kind of stuff. How do you keep track of everything? How, how are you remembering these
gadgets? Is it all just like a bulletin board in your mind that is very just like fragile or, or do you,
are you writing stuff down? Like, can you talk a little bit about that?
I wish I can hardly remember what I had for breakfast yesterday. Um, mostly it's a discord
channel with people. Like mostly if I find something interesting, anything interesting whatsoever,
I'll post like the JavaScript file I found it in, if it was a JavaScript file and then like the route,
and then maybe talk a little bit about it because I'm normally trying to communicate it to somebody
else in the group chat. Like, Hey, this is interesting for this reason. So I kind of like catalog that
and I can go back to it. Um, and then like telling messages, things like that. But for building out,
like, you know, unlike the longer engagements, like building out and understanding, it's a lot of like,
you know, maybe you go to developer.company.com, you register for an API key and you kind of look
through their API requests. So for instance, uh, we can kind of transition this if you wanted to,
but we found a vulnerability. I think it was on, uh, Vercel. Um, yeah, but Vercel is a really good
example because for Vercel, Vercel has this API where they talk about like all of their API requests
that you can make yourself as a developer. And there's a custom endpoint on the Vercel website
that takes in a parameter of your account ID. And it basically generates a screenshot of your website.
So it was like slash account ID slash...
Very fun functionality there. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. It was super fun. Um, but what was really interesting is that when you give it the
parameter for the website, so it's like your slash account ID slash website ID, maybe like one,
two, three, slash one, two, three, four or something, you could actually, um, traverse the one, two,
three, four and overwrite the full API call. And what, what I realized is that from reading the normal
documentation for Vercel, it was actually making the API request to itself. That was a normal documented
process that you could read as a person, right? So we reproduced it and we realized that what it
was doing is it was fetching a JSON response from a particular endpoint and it was parsing out the
URL parameter. So this API request to make a screenshot, it would pull the URL from the website ID.
And then it took a screenshot of that specified URL. But what it was doing...
How did you suss that out? How did you know that it was pulling that from the JSON response? You had
to have seen the response somehow, right? So I never, I never saw, saw the response, but what I did is I,
figured out the request by, I did the thing that, you know, Fran said where you're backtracking every
single request until you rebuild the full request. And then, uh, in that response, I was like, it has
to be hitting this specific endpoint. And the only thing from this response that makes sense is the
URL parameter. What? So yeah, it's, this is the kind of shit I'm talking about, dude. Like how? So, so, so you
traverse back, you look at the path and then you just say, okay, guess, uh, there is going to be
in the, the JSON response at the root level, no, like data, you know, data, colon this or whatever,
there's going to be a URL attribute. And then they're going to read that. And that's the only
thing they're reading from the response. Are you kidding me?
Yeah. It's a bit of like, you know, there's, you use the website enough a little bit. I don't
know. There's just something like you slowly build it up, I think from like hacking on the same target for
a while. Right. And then like, you can leverage that. Like, and I think the, I think the final
exploit for that was like, uh, you could upload your own data to Vercel and then you could backtrack
the API to load your own data. And then you would load your uploaded JSON and it would sign that URL.
And then you could basically load anybody's staging domains or bypass their SSO. Because what it was
doing was, uh, like, you know, signing that URL using your own token. So like, or signing the URL using
a master token from Vercel that had access to everybody's stuff. Right. Um, wow. Yeah.
I mean, so let me get this straight. This is nuts. So what you did is you find a secondary context
path traversal. You identify by using whatever the heck that was a second ago, big brain nonsense,
that you need to put a URL. Sam, I really actually can't even wrap my head around this. No,
cause you're not even getting a hit. You're not even hitting an external server. What you're guessing
is that you went all the way through this, this whole thing, and then you uploaded a JSON file
to the account and then traversed and hit that. And then you were deciding, okay, I need to put a URL
parameter in there, like a URL JSON value in there. Sam, that's ridiculous. That doesn't make any
freaking sense, Sam. Well, it's a lot of, uh, I don't know. It's a lot of guessing is what it sounds like.
It made sense to me that day. It's a lot of guessing and intuition, which, which is very,
for me, that is definitely not my strong suit in bounties. Like most of my stuff is very much,
Yeah. I think logically oriented and logical flows, but this was a lot of guessing and a lot of intuition.
What, I mean, is it, is it just something that you feel when you're doing this? Because that like,
and I can, I can understand that in some scenarios, like the Franz thing, um, with traversing back and
then guessing the path, like that amazes me for sure, but I can understand it a little bit. Cause
like, okay, you know, you understand the architecture of APIs, but something like this, where you're
guessing the structure of the response and you don't even have it hitting your own server. So it's not,
but you have to like upload a JSON file and then traverse to that and then
help. Yeah. Yeah. So, so, so I was, I, I'd like to say, um,
you mentioned intuition here and I was listening yesterday to a really interesting podcast about
intuition and like when you can and cannot trust your intuition. Okay. And intuition is one of those
things that's like really built up over time, um, as like a skill where like, uh, back to chess,
right? You see this all the time with chess or chess grandmasters. Um, they have played chess for so
long that they have a mental intuition of what moves make the most sense, even if they can't really
explain why it makes sense because they've done it so many times for so long. They've thought about
so many different hands and scenarios and moves and everything that they're like, you know, this makes
the most sense. I can't really explain why, but it does. And they're right. Um, and I think a lot of
that is the same with bug bounty where it's like this intuition that you hone in over time, um, both on
individual targets, but also like as a whole. Right. So I think, uh, I was, I was looking back through our
messages because, uh, like a month ago, you, you'd said this thing that really stuck with me and you're
like, there's a five day hump on any program quote Franz Rosen on this. And if you brute force, brute
brute force past this, you become an unstoppable force. And I love that because I think that is like
your intuition being like, hang on a second. I'm a, I'm a dull right now. You got to sharpen me up a
little bit. And after five days, then you've got this specific intuition for the target you're looking
at, right? Like when you're testing stuff and you're like, you know, it's gotta be a URL
parameter in the, in the response to this JSON body. It's because you've got five plus days of
like banging your head against the wall, basically going back and forth with like, what is this
developer doing? Like, what, why, why did they make this choice? Oh, they do things like that.
Oh, okay. That's weird. But all right. I guess that's just how they do things. And you just sort of
build this, this like understanding of how a specific company does things internally. Um, and back to the
intuition part, right? When you can trust your intuition is when you're in an environment that
is like slow to change. And so, especially when you've honed your intuition on a target, that target
is not going to be like yesterday, we were doing things this day, this way, but tomorrow we're going
to do it completely differently. Yeah. Right. And so you can actually hone your intuition on a target,
like really, really well, because you do understand how they do things. You can build up an understanding,
like implicitly internally of like, okay, this is probably how they're actually doing this.
And I think like, that's something that you do a really good job of capitalizing on.
Right. I totally agree with that. Like the, uh, that happened to like Tesla.
I, this is sort of a similar bug where it's like,
Don't, don't, I'm sorry.
Hold on. I'm not letting you weasel your way out of that last one. Okay. Don't even start with me right now.
Okay. So, so, okay. We're going to go to that one and I want to hear that one,
but let's just, you know, rewind a little bit here and, and finish this one up. Okay. So you
do some big brain and you figure out, okay, there's a URL parameter. What do you put in the URL,
the URL parameter in the parameter, JSON attribute in the response, uh, of this traversed backend API
request. Are you putting in your own host? Are you putting in, uh, initially or.
Yeah. So originally what I did is I put in my own host and I saw that there's a
like signed header, which is like a session. It's like, this is the URL signed that way
the server can like access it, you know, because we're cells, God key is being signed here and it
loads. I wish it would just send you a God key, man.
I agree. Like I, I was, I was kind of annoyed by it. Um, and funny enough, one of the reasons that
like we ended up going so deep on this bug is, uh, I think Ian Carroll knows how to like
psychologically manipulate me because, uh, whenever we hacked together, he just tells me I was sitting
next to him at a hotel and, uh, we were trying to hack on Bricell and he's like, there's no bug there.
Like he can't find anything. I'm like, I'm going to show you, like, I will pull a bug out.
Like if it's like through a tiny little like fishing wire.
It's starting to make sense now. Ian was, Ian was trolling you into this bug. Okay. I see.
He did this at, uh, he did this at the, uh, recently. Yeah. But, but yeah, like there,
I tested my own URL. I saw I was sending a request. I saw it was signed. And then I was like,
well, I can't really sign anything arbitrarily. Cause I tried all the bypasses. I did like
backslash at, you know, at, uh, credentials, basic off, you know, to try to get it to sign a URL
that like try to parse out, uh, part one of the URL where it's like HBS victim.com or HBS, uh,
sorry, victim.com backslash at attacker.com where like it would sign the URL for the victim website,
but give me the signed credentials. And then I could take those credentials and authenticate.
But what ended up happening that was a lot easier is we could just pass in the victim URL directly.
So there's no bypass needed because it would just screenshot the website.
So what you were trying to do there was somehow leak to yourself the signed headers, but, but
you know, the request has to be sent to you. So it, it, it isn't going to work that way. Right.
Cause you can only sign things that are going to be pointing towards your own domain.
So then you just put in the victim's website directly and use the functionality on the website.
Exactly. Right. Cause I was, I was annoyed. I was like, there has to be some like differentiator
between the HB requests actually firing and then like the security parsing for the URL. So I was
looking for any difference between the two, right? Because if the security parsing was slightly different.
Yeah, exactly. Um, but yeah, that was kind of the process for that.
How did you, no, no, no, no, no, no, Sam. But then, then how did you, how did you know the,
I mean, did you just pass in? Was it just like HGPS victim.com? Whatever?
Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It was very simple for that part.
Okay. So you, you don't, you didn't have to like guess some sort of path or anything like that
with the IDs for the victim. It was literally just, you give them the victim website and it just
returns you an image of the victim's website. Exactly. Yeah. And I was really happy with that.
Very simple. So that part was simple. Okay. Yeah.
Very cool, man. Okay. So now talk about Tesla.
Sure. So yes, intuition, you honed your intuition and you said this, this happened on Tesla as well.
Yeah, sure. So for Tesla, I was really frustrated because like, I really want, I have, I own a Tesla
and I like, I really wanted to hack it for a while. And the Tesla API is like really fascinating because
like there's like a single API for the Tesla owners to use that can do all the stuff for the Tesla cars.
And the authorization, a lot of times, one thing I noticed a lot for like certain companies is
they'll do this thing where they'll, they'll sign a JWT or something and then they'll have the value
in the URL where it's like, maybe it's email at email.com and then in the URL, they'll pass them like
email at email.com. And then to validate that you're off, they just compare the two, right?
For Tesla in particular, I noticed they had an account ID or a vehicle ID and I was like in the JWT.
So, or jot, however you want to say it. Don't correct me.
No.
But, but anyway, the-
Nobody's right on that one.
Yeah, good stuff. But for Tesla is really cool because there's this endpoint where you pass in the vehicle ID
and it was like signing a JWT, but what you could actually do is it was using a particular integer parsing
where if you appended like ABC at the end of the integer, it would run parseEnt on it where it would only retrieve the number.
So in the actual logic check for authorization, it would pull out, you know, parseEnt, whatever you provided,
check if it's, you know, valid and that you're authorized to access it.
And then it would take the raw value that you originally sent and it would send it in a second request, right?
So what you could actually do that was really neat is you could do like your ID, %2f, .%2f, victim ID.
And then it would basically, it would bypass the check via the parseEnt and then it would take your raw request,
but it would actually on the backend traverse to the victim account and then you get access to the victim's vehicle.
Wow, dude. Okay. So I'm looking at this. So the reason that works is parseInt in JavaScript.
If you pass it a string that says 1234 slash test, it will return 1234.
1234. Yeah, exactly. Right.
That's hecked up. That's some JS shit if I've ever seen it.
Yeah.
But that's really helpful to know, especially on node targets, because it's like,
they might be using parseInt to get the integer value for this thing. And then if they're using that,
so then they don't use the parsed value, they use the original value again in the second backend API request.
Exactly. And that's the fun part because you can just provide in like the victim ID.
It's really neat. And there's a similar thing too with PHP. This is a kind of one,
some people, like I said, know is that there's a dollar sign underscore request. There's dollar sign
underscore get and dollar sign underscore post and put and whatever. Right. But what's really
interesting is that if you do dollar sign request and you do a logic check with dollar sign request,
like let's say the ID parameter, and then you validate that parameter, you can actually do,
if for any reason it switches to get or post after that, request could be like the one from the get
and then post could just be the one from the post. What I'm trying to say is that request is indifferent
to, or request is like specific to one of those. It's either get or post and the logic switches up
once you switch to like either get or post where you can basically provide like
question mark ID equals one, two, three in the URL.
And then in the post body you provide one, two, four and request pulls the top one.
And then post is the second one.
Ah, interesting.
It's like a lot of, you've seen that in the backend, in the same backend API call.
So like, like where you'll put the, the victim's ID or let's say your ID in the URL. And then
is this a part of the normal functionality of this application where they have the ID in two spots,
or you say, or is you specifically adding?
I, yeah, specifically adding.
That's freaking weird.
That's super weird.
It was funny.
Yeah. It was really funny too. Cause it was a four, I was playing like a Korean MMO,
which was like super grindy. And like, you had to pay like a hundred dollars. You wanted to like
level your character up or get a special item or something. And I ended up reporting a bug,
so don't get mad at me yet. But what you could do is it would have like your package value. So it's like a
$400 package and it'd be passed that in. And then it would sign the whole request and pass it off to
the payment provider. But what you could do is like, and the get request, you're like, okay,
fine, I'll pay $500. And then the post request you do, ah, let's actually change it to a penny.
And that gives you the sign checkout URL that's passed to like the payment provider. And you complete
the checkout process and you can only buy it for a penny. So then you get your $500 package.
And I think I got a really funny email from the game developer. It says, we noticed some erratic
activity in your account. You spent $3 million.
Yeah, that's what I'm talking about. Like, why do you do this shit? Like,
I understand the hacking things that you don't have like, you know.
I would love to know the thought process actually. Like when you receive an eval like that,
are you excited or you're like, oh shit. Like, uh oh.
It's a little bit of both. I hope they understand that like, my thing is like, I like to like walk the
line between both. It's like, I hope you're not gonna like, full out like, sue me and get me in
trouble. And I hope that me doing it isn't like, too terrible for you to deal with. I think it's
similar to like, maybe if I did $100 or $1000 or whatever. But like, I don't know that that line
is like, interesting to walk. I think.
Better to ask for forgiveness than permission.
Yeah, exactly.
You know, like, I think like, it's a very particular thing because like, you try, I try my best not to
like actually, I'm not like going out and impacting the game economy. I'm immediately contacting them
to report it. And like, they're aware of my account and stuff, you know.
But you still have the coolest game for sure.
Exactly right. Like, well, it's funny too, because my buddy, a long time ago when I was like 11 or 12
years old, even I played video games with this guy named Buzzman and Buzzman did video game hacking.
And he did tons of video game hacking. And I looked up to him a lot. And he was like this
Belgian researcher. And then when I was 17, I checked his Facebook and he runs like the,
one of the biggest game security companies.
No way.
And he actually had these people as a client and I like passed it to him and he got good PR.
He's like, hello, we found a bug from, you know, and this researcher reported it.
So really funny story, but Buzzman is a genius. Yeah. Very smart guy.
Wow. So, okay. So, so just to bring that back to the technical takeaway there,
which was sometimes you can add parameters to the, see, you know, and this is a very common
IDOR tactic as well, you know, where you'll see a, you know, an ID in the URL parameter and in the
post body. And what it'll do is the auth check for the URL and then not auth check the post body.
So that, that one's a well-established, I, you know, IDOR mentality, but this is,
this is also applying in, in this sort of scenario where you can get, you can add it specifically to
one or the other. And I, I kind of, right. I, I kind of am curious how that actually would work on
the backend. Cause it's like, okay. You know, I can see how they would do path level authorization in
those other scenarios, but I can't really see how they'd be like, all right, you know, let's just say
it's PHP here, uh, dollar sign underscore get, you know, that, and then check it, but maybe it's,
it's request, but then it's overriding it, you know, but you, you know what I'm saying? Like,
how does this work?
Yeah. So I think what originally happened was it was a put request and the auth check was using
underscore request. Right. And when it was a put request, I think PHP was like, oh, cool. It's a request.
It's a put request. It's coming from the body. Right. But then any actual logic of the application,
it did underscore get right. Weird. So auth check request,
actual functionality was get. Yeah, exactly.
Well, maybe there's like, if there's a get parameter that has this specific, you know,
like user ID or whatever, then perform the auth check and then auth check equals true or whatever,
you know, after that. Yeah.
That could be a two. Wow. Very interesting, Sam. I hadn't, I had never thought of that. That's,
that's a, that's a pretty cool one to take away. Um, and that's mostly regarding authorization stuff
for these, or I guess, like you said, it could override values, application level values as well.
And it makes me think of a, um, client side path traversal that I recently found, which is my,
my shit right now. I just love client side path traversal vulnerabilities, but essentially what it
was is, um, you know, the, the target would send a, an empty, uh, post request to a given endpoint.
Once I've done the client side path traversal in the URL, um, and I needed to, to send parameters in that,
that request, um, and to, to, to, you know, manipulate the application level logic, add an admin user to
the organization. And what I did instead was just added them to the query parameter with the path traversal.
So I just did, you know, question marks. Yeah. I use it equals one, two, three, you know, and, you know,
add type equals admin. Yeah. And you see this a lot actually, where, where modern web frameworks,
they've made it significantly easier to use one thing to reference parameters, right? Whether
that's get or post, or it's like, I just want, I don't really care how it comes in. If it's post
request or get request, I just want the parameter called ID, right? It makes my web application more
flexible for, but for an attacker, it's like, okay, well, what if I provide both? Like what is,
what is request.parameters ID now? Yeah. I really, I really like that. That that's pretty rad.
Very, very cool tip. I'm trying to look through here and see some of the other things we have
associated with secondary context path traversals before we move on to some of your research oriented
stuff. The other thing that I see here is, so we covered fuzzing for endpoints. We've kind of
mentioned this on the, on the pod before, but figuring out where you are in that sort of backend API
is something you're really good at. And also, actually, I want to come back because we didn't
finish the Starbucks, the Starbucks thing. One of the other things that I realized was really awesome
about your Starbucks path traversal was that the traversal was slash or backslash dot dot backslash
dot backslash, right? That was the traversal sequence, right? Where normally it's just dot dot slash
or, you know, dot dot backslash. But in this one, you had to space it out with dots in between.
Why were you doing that? And what kind of similar methodologies do you have with that that may help?
Yeah. At the time, I think that was an Akamai WAF bypass, which is really funny because Akamai has grown so much
since then. Yeah. So if you did like dot dot slash dot slash, it's like, stop, that's too many
backward slashes. But you're like dot slash dot slash dot dot slash. And I was like, all right,
you know, like that checks out. And I think maybe Akamai even like in the blog post, it was like kind
of a call out because I was like, yeah, WAFs are bad. This is why this worked. So I think maybe they're
like, damn, we got to fix our paths. Not saying Akamai is, I'm the reason Akamai fixed their thing, but
it was a little call out to Akamai. I was like, damn, this was like kind of embarrassing. You guys need to get
yourself together. Maybe pay better. So I mean, when you're doing this, I've seen you do like even
spaces and new line character. What kind of stuff are you trying in order to achieve these back end
traversals? And what kind of stuff have you seen work with any consistency?
Yeah. So one person who really kind of helped and like kind of get my methodology good for this is
Andre or sorry, Andre 0xACB. Andre Baptista, I think is how you say his last name, but he is
one of the best, like has one of the best methodologies. He even made a tool for this where
it's like, if you're trying to traverse directories, there are certain areas where you should be fuzzing.
So for instance, you could do dot dot percent zero zero to FF slash. So then instead of, you would
basically add before the slash a character there and then you enumerate through all the hex code. And then,
you know, maybe percent zero D gets removed when it gets like transacted to the next API.
Yeah. And then it turns into-
This is re-collapse? Is that right?
Yeah. Re-collapse. Yeah. Re-collapse is great. So my methodology for like trying to figure out
if directory traversal works is like, try the normal stuff, you know, dot dot, backslash,
dot dot, percent zero D slash, dot dot, whatever. But then if I can't figure it out, I'll just send
it to intruder and then do zero zero to FF. And I've had like really, yeah, I've had some good
luck just like with random stuff, like percent zero nine, like a tab or something sometimes for like
dot net applications would work. And yeah, it's really fun.
I like that whole brute force, the URL per, or the URL decoding space, essentially, percent zero zero to
percent FF. That's quite good. And I use that often as well. And, you know, sometimes there's some weird
Unicode bypasses that that won't hit. But those are pretty, pretty rare edge cases. And I kind of,
that's something that I would like to put a little bit more thought into is how can we apply
like, I essentially, I mean, there's too many Unicode characters, so we can just brute force
the whole Unicode space, but it would be really interesting to categorize like, okay, these are like
white space-ish Unicode characters or something like that, that might get converted and make those
into a list for brute forcing as well, because that would be really helpful to have in that,
in that list as well.
A hundred percent. And there was a good blog post too. I think it was like,
Unicode S's for GitHub to bypass email OAuth flows. I could maybe Google it really quick. It was
GitHub Unicode bug bounty. Let's see.
I'll find it.
You said it was GitHub?
The Google part. Turkish, yeah. Turkish Dotless Eye.
Turkish Dotless Eye.
Um, yeah.
Oh, wow.
This is, this is one of my favorites. Andre has another thing for this. I don't,
I'm not going to give the exact URL, but it's some somewhere on his website. He has a normalization
table that I use all the time. And it's, it's very similar to this where it's just like,
you know, all the standard characters and then under every single one, it's just a list of all the
normalization possibilities, like different varieties and stuff of that character. And you
can just go through and you can try them, you know, on your, on your, you know, your target. And I use
that all the time when I'm trying to bypass filters. Yeah. It's super useful.
Yeah. I'll send you a link to it. We'll keep in mind.
Yeah. I'm going to DM you right now to send, send me Unicode list. That's great. Okay. So,
so Sam, just why don't you talk us through this? So hacking GitHub's OAuth with Unicode Turkish
Dotless Eye, how does this work?
Yeah. So I think it was a email issue where basically like GitHub supported a bunch of
different OAuth flows. So I think that when you did, scroll through really quick.
Ah, so they would put the Turkish Dotless Eye after the G in GitHub at GitHub.com.
Right. Oh, yeah, exactly. And, and then, yeah, it emails the original one and actually showed this
up as the second one. So you could just basically steal people's. So I think what happened was like the
email client or the authorization was like, oh, that's, you know, a different domain. That's not
GitHub.com. But yeah, there's an issue there somewhere where it confused both.
These, these Unicode normalization bugs are, every time I see this, I think of Andre
because of his just legendary bugs he's pulled off at almost every live hacky event he's been to.
He's done something with crazy with these Unicode normalization bugs.
Yeah. There's a lot of stuff. I mean, Andre is one of those people, I think that,
especially us three have pulled a lot of, we've done a lot of hacking with him and we pulled a lot
of inspiration off of him as well. Like even just like the leaking header stuff that we were talking
about earlier, like that was Andre's first LHE. Uh, NVH was leaking a token through like an external
request to his server from like an internal, you know, thing that was like a master token, like same,
you know, very, very, very, very similar type stuff. And that was five plus years ago.
So here we are in full circle. Yeah.
That was crazy.
And I, yeah, I have to call it out too. Cause like Andre's one of those people where it's not
just computers. Like when he's hacking, he's like, this is the galaxy. Like this is the matrix. Like
we're in space right now, like going through like portals and like, it's so much larger than just
like an API for him. It's like, yeah, it's, I love the energy is so good. Love Andre.
I love Andre's energy. Yeah. Yeah. So actually on the topic of energy and we'll circle, we can,
we can circle back to technical stuff, but this was something on the philosophy thing that I did
want to want to highlight with you. Um, you have this really intense energy, um, in a good way.
Like when it, when it comes to hacking, like you, when you are focused on a target, Justin always
describes me as like a laser beam that he can, uh, he can nerd snipe to point in the right direction.
And I, I, I view Sam as like, uh, the death star Ray in that same sense. Right. So like,
it's like a hundred X where, when you're really fixated on something, when you're focused on like,
I want to get this thing, like, there's nothing that's going to really stop you from doing that.
Um, and you have like this, like industrial sized fan on your flame. Right. So how do you like,
how are you able to like, do you, does it just come naturally all the time? Like you just find
yourself in these situations or do you find, um, that you fall out of that headspace and that you
have to do certain things to get yourself back in there? Yeah. I don't know. I think honestly,
a lot of it stems from like, uh, hacking was like one of the original things where it's like,
I felt like a, this is going to sound so like convoluted psychologist, whatever, but like the,
uh, original, like a sense of, uh, I don't know, appreciation was like finding something cool.
So like, I have this really deep down thing where it's like, if I want to like prove a point and like
find the bug, that's how I feel like a sense of validation from my peers and stuff or whatever.
So like, if I, if I have a goal, which I feel like is like interesting to me and like,
I prove a point to somebody or something like that, you know, like, it's like, I want to,
I'm going to do it. So like it, it transitions and it comes up pretty naturally where like,
I'm like, yo, like that thing looks interesting and I bet I could do it. Um, and it's like a fun,
I don't know how to describe it, but it, it comes very naturally where it's like,
you know, for instance, like,
Yes. Something just get like, gets under your skin a little bit. Like Ian being like,
there's nothing here or like whatever it is, or, or you just being like,
that's really interesting. I wonder if that's possible or whatever it is.
Exactly.
Just sort of like following that, that, that dopamine or whatever that, that interest.
Yes. Example, a perfect example of that, like recently too, is like, uh,
is it okay if I transition to the ISP hacking a little bit?
Go for it.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
So, uh, yeah, like I, I had a call on my ISP technician because like I moved into a new
house and like, I couldn't get it set up and like, it was just kind of frustrating. They're like,
I'm going to remotely change your password. I'm like, you can do that. Like you can remotely
change my motor's password. I was like, I had no idea that was possible. And I was like,
I wonder what they have access to to do that.
Oh my gosh.
I have a, yeah, it was, it was fascinating because I'm like, this is really cool. So like,
I spent a while investigating my own ISP and I eventually found this vulnerability because like
deep down at the core of the ISP, they had built this internal API called SAIL. And what SAIL was used
for was customer support agents and normal people to manage their router, to push commands, to
update their router, view router settings. And it was called SAIL. And it would basically
bypass the authorization layer to do things like update DNS or fetch device password or things like
that. And I was like, if that's possible, not just reset to fetch it as well.
You can do everything. I mean, you can do-
This is the modem, right?
This is, this is the modem and this is the modem they issued everybody. It's not just their ISP modem.
It's any compatible modem. It's fascinating, right? Because to even go back two years ago,
to give a little even more context is like, I was hacked. Like I got hacked. I was on my laptop and I
curled the box. And what I realized was that a third party digital ocean IP was resending my
exact same HB requests. So I thought originally my computer was owned and then I opened the URL on
my iPhone and I saw the exact same digital ocean IP was resending that same traffic. So somebody
somewhere was like intercepting my traffic and I researched it and it was an IP that was related to
like a phishing campaign. And basically what I think happened was someone had compromised my modem,
right? And sorry for so much background to this, but it got me really interested in like hacking ISPs.
But anyway, I found a way to remotely, you can remotely take over anybody's router. You can update
their DNS, update their password settings, things like that via just their serial number.
How did you find that API in the first place?
Yeah. So what it was, was there's a ISP that was affected. There's a business management website. So for
business customers, and they have access to like a little bit more functionality. So if you're a business
customer and you want to manage your router modem to like update stuff remotely or see the connected
devices remotely, it would take in your request and like pass it down. And what I realized is that there
is a bypass to traverse down and access the swagger files for the API routes.
Sorry, I'm going to pause you and back up a little bit there.
Yep.
Why do you, why did you, why were you looking at the business? I mean, do you have access to that business
panel yourself or, or were you just looking at this as like, oh, this looks like something related?
Yeah, that's, that's what I was doing originally. Well, what I originally assumed is that there isn't any
segmentation between and I thought that at the protocol level from a support level, it's using
the same like sale protocol. I assumed it was based on the protocol beforehand or no.
I'm just trying to get into that a little bit. Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. Sorry. A little bit here.
I think at the time I didn't know about that. It was specifically called sale, but I realized that
there's a tool set internally and there was like a little documentation that was like scattered across
like GitHub or whatever, where it had like reset device or whatever. But to clarify, like I knew
it was possible and then I, I kind of thought about it and there's the customer facing website,
which is very restricted and locked down. And then there's like the business website, which has,
you know, if you're like a business, you can manage more stuff. You have multiple devices.
It's like an easier interface. Right. So that was the thought process, but I dug at the business website
and I eventually found an API, which let you do those sale commands. And I found the second
vulnerability where there's a leaked secret, which was used to encrypt the router serial number
in the pipe and the flow. So I could basically decrypt and encrypt any router serial number that was
passed in that protocol to do like anything. So you could...
Was this an unauthed API or were you authed into the business website?
Well, it was a fully unauthed. Yeah, it was unauthed. Everything was...
And you found it in the JS files or were you brute forcing it?
It was in... Yeah. JavaScript. It was basically, the flow was website to JavaScript to directory
traversal to swagger files to API call from a traversal. So it was like a secondary context thing
where you traverse to another internal routing thing. And then in the JavaScript, it has the encrypt
functionality because I saw the router value and I was like, that's not a normal string. So I realized
it's encrypted so you can decrypt it. And then through that, you could... It's absurd to think
about to me because if you're the FBI, you have an office building that uses this ISP for your internet,
right? And if someone was to man in the middle of your network, they'd have to go into your network
and do the whatever. But you can just update DNS via the serial number and it's innumerable.
And it's just... We could also search by customers by name or business name. So it's like you could
target... It's just... Wow, dude. That's crazy.
Yeah. Yeah.
So go ahead, Joel. Sorry.
Right.
Joel Sander Well, and this is on your ISP.
He's like, you know, one of the largest... I mean, they also have a monopoly where I live. They're
like one of two ISPs in my area. I think most people use them. And, you know, they're a huge,
huge, massive megacorp. Did they even have a security contact? Like, I'm almost certain they don't have
a bug bounty program, right?
Joel Sander No, they had like a... They maybe had a security page, like a responsible... They did have a
responsible disclosure page, but you had to like go through a couple of people that actually get to
somebody. Yeah. They didn't really seem to have like a super sophisticated... I couldn't find a
security contact. They maybe had a CISO, but they weren't reachable. They didn't have an email or
LinkedIn that accepted the invite or anything like that.
Joel Sander Wow.
Joel Sander Yeah. No way to contact it.
So let me just... I'm going to try to concisely do this because, Sam, this is really something special,
like the way that you have found this whole path. And it's something a little bit more foreign to me,
because for me, a lot of what hacking looks like is get the main application, figure out all of the
functionality, figure out all of the logic, find all the requests, start correlating information,
deep dive the stack, that sort of thing. But this whole thinking about it from an architectural level
is very different. So you had a call with a support agent, the support agent said the wrong thing to
Mr. Sam Curry and said, I'm going to reset your...
Sam Curry's like, mental note. Very interesting. Oh, thanks. Okay. Bye.
Exactly. That lit a fire. And you're thinking, okay, so they have some way to
remotely reset my router. I bet that it's easier to access that through the business portal than it is
through the customer report. Maybe you went to the customer portal first or whatever, and then,
but then you decided to go to the business portal. Go to the business portal, no auth,
no, nothing. That doesn't scare you off. You're just looking at the JS files, you find unopped API
access that you can have, you pass the verse that hit the swagger. Then using the swagger, you find,
I mean, I imagine the swagger, did it have documentation in it for all the, yeah. Okay.
So at that point you're like, all right, I'm good to go. Then from the swagger file,
you're, are you hitting, is it a reverse proxy or is it a secondary context thing on
that API or was it a secondary context thing before that to hit the swagger file?
It was a secondary context to hit the swagger file and that opened the door. Everything was
connected at that point in the secondary context. And then now you've got the keys to the kingdom
with the swagger file and the unauthed API, and you can just encrypt and decrypt IDs because of that
secret. And then you can take over any, any freaking router in your whole ISP. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. It's crazy to think about this. It's like, and shout out to Zayat for helping
with the JavaScript too, because the encrypt function was at a certain point. So it set
a break point in the JavaScript to actually call that JavaScript. Zayat's the master at this. He's
done like a lot of really cool research. So if you're setting an encrypt, or if you're setting a
break point, then that JS would have to be triggering, which I imagine would only happen after auth, right?
So did he have to like somehow hijack that flow and trigger that function or?
Zayat's the master. So there was a submit registration endpoint that you could hit and
it would encrypt your pen code. So you didn't actually get approved or anything, but you could
encrypt your, like, you know, one, two, three, four, it would send encrypt the value.
Gotcha. And so that's how I found it.
That's awesome. Yeah.
That's awesome. This is such a cool, a cool little like pocket of research too, because
I've thought a lot about this. Like modems are such a weird spot. A lot of modems, especially like the
provided ones, they don't give you any way to interface with them, right? Like my modem, for
example, has like a fiber line going into it. It's an ONT, I guess, but, and then it just outputs
ethernet to my, you know, my, my network. Right. But how do I talk to the, the box that like gets
fiber, right? Like that is, can that's talking to the ISP that does some theoretically some
negotiation or communication back with the ISP so that some random person can just plug a fiber in and
get internet for free. Right. Right. Like, you know, it's like, how, how does all that work?
It's such a, such a weird, like, yeah, I, I love just like peering into that. I think there's a lot
more interesting research you could do there. The ONT boxes too are super proprietary, like proprietary.
Like I had the, the guy was at my house and I was like, could I buy one of those? He's like, nope,
they got to come from the ISP and you go to the ONT website. Yeah. Yeah. You can't buy them yourself.
Like you can maybe get off eBay, but yeah, very proprietary. That would be such a fun live hacking
event. If some like, you know, Verizon or Cox or whatever is just like, all right, here's your
house. And they give us a little like, you know, you know, that would be so that'd be awesome.
I love it. All right, dude. So that was a, that was a great, a great phone story. Thank you for
getting into the technical details with that. That really helps me understand from a bigger perspective,
what your methodology is for finding these sort of fringe assets and going after these goals that
you've got. The next one that I kind of want to talk about is your next, next JS research that you did
2022, I think. And if I understand correctly, this was a, was something that came from the fact that a
lot of companies are using this framework now, specifically in the crypto space. And that motivated
you to look into it. Right. Right. Exactly. Like one big thing for me was like, uh, with crypto,
it's always been kind of crazy to me because like the huge thing for crypto is integrity. Right. If
you look at the CIA triad, confidentiality is like, the only thing you need to really worry about is like
leaking your keys, uh, being like availability. It's like, if it goes down, it's like, whatever,
you still have a chain access. It's like a static website who cares. Right. But the integrity is like,
super important. Right. So like, if I'm a normal person and I want to go to Uniswap to like trade
a million dollars for this, for a million dollars of that, I trust Uniswap.org. And I'm not really
going to do too much additional verification. Like, you know, nobody's doing like hash verifications of
the JavaScript or whatever they're in. It's all very like MetaMask, swap. I trust the domain name.
Right. So the idea for me is like, if you can get XSS on Next.js, which is what all the crypto
websites use, then you have this like huge, huge integrity issue where it's like, you know,
there's nonstop phishing domains. And this was the first case that I'd personally seen
someone leverage subdomain takeover for a phishing domain because I saw on Twitter,
someone had taken over like something.ferrari.com and then hosted like an NFT giveaway or something.
Right. And it's like, yeah, it was really cool to see. Cause I'm like, Hey, subdomain takeover,
like someone's actually exploiting that for like the most of its purpose. Right.
That's not good. Yeah, exactly. And the one actual instance of it being
exploited in the wild. Exactly. Like, so that, that was always fascinating to me. So like the Next.js,
like every single website you proxy, you see underscore next and you're like, Oh my God,
same thing over and over and over. So for me, it's like, let's investigate this. And maybe there's
like a core issue because personally, like Vercel and Netlify and all these companies, they're like,
great, they're great companies, but like the bloat associated with it. There's a really funny quote
actually from like Whitey Cracker on a blog he wrote a long time ago. And he says, if any one of these,
like all it takes is like one of these like friends, JavaScript framework developers to die,
like Adderall overdose. And like a quarter of the internet goes down. Nobody can ever fix it again
because like it's such a particular library. So yeah. Like the XZ thing that that's happening right now,
like live XZ, we came like so close, just like graze the sun with, with how that could have been.
And it's the same thing, right? It's like all it takes is one really widely used library or framework
or something to get popped in a fundamental way. And everybody's like, everyone's, oh,
shit. That affects everything. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. And for, for Next.js, especially too,
it's like at the time I was so focused on crypto. I was like, let's try to target all the crypto websites.
So I worked with Shubs on this one and we went deep on the source code for the actual like image
proxy functionality. Basically what they've done is they've baked in this like image optimization
feature where, you know, maybe in the past you've had like an external image that has to load each
time. But like, instead of reaching out to the other website, it does the closer server and it
optimizes it and caches it. So you don't have to like waste the network traffic. So what that actually
does is like the server itself is originally making that request to fetch the image, right?
So if you loaded like, I think it was underscore IPX slash external URL, it would, or underscore IPX
slash trusted URL, like percent 2F image.png. What you could actually do through investigating the source
code is you could add a header to overwrite the external URL that it reaches out to, and then it
would cache it. And we, what we realized is that you could do, yeah, SVG files. And by doing an
external SVG file and caching it on that URL, you could save like percent 2F test.html or test.svg.
And then it would cache the XSS payload, you could send it to somebody else.
And since it was at like a library level, you could do it like on any website, right?
Yeah.
And so did you get that from reading the source code for that? I imagine that wasn't just experimentation.
No, yeah, it was a bit of both. Mostly it was source code because like you could trace,
everything is public, which is kind of, it's one of like those like Silicon Valley, like open source,
but sort of will like give you a trial or something.
So yeah, I actually want to ask about this because I think I'm being a little, I don't fully understand
the whole infrastructure for this. So obviously we see a lot of Next.js stuff on the client side,
but is this, is this, you know, I'm having a little bit of trouble correlating this to what it is. I mean,
obviously they've got some server side functionality. We see a bunch of stuff with that on the client side.
Is it like a full stack solution for that or?
Yeah. So Next.js is, it's a full stack solution or it's kind of like a framework. It's essentially what
it is, is a JavaScript framework and it does both front end and back end. So, and what's it's,
it's offered by, I think, Vercel. Vercel is the original, they're the original builders maybe of,
of Next.js. And Vercel is like, here's Next.js. And if you really want an easy way to deploy it,
just come to our website. Right. So a lot of Next.js that you see is actually deployed through
Vercel's website through a sort of like AWS setup. Right.
This is a full, and this is very interesting. So there's, there's certain trade-offs between the,
the server side and the client side that are baked right into it, just like this image optimization thing.
I see why that this, this sort of put off the alarms in your head, because I hadn't really looked at the
structure before, but what I had seen is like, it does make me think a little bit of this, this cloud
flare stuff that I, that we talked about on the pod maybe last week or a couple of weeks ago,
of like these slash CDN CGI endpoint that's on literally every single website. There's gotta be some
weird stuff there, man. I swear. Right. Yeah. I mean, there's a lot of things that are like this,
right? Like imagine if somebody finds an XSS in Google tag manager, like, yeah, it's like every
website in the world. It's, you know, yeah. I think I was hacking on like, that was one of those
things where it's like, I was hacking on like some really hardened target and it was used by everybody.
It was like something similar to like Venmo or something like that. Right. And what I saw was
that there was a JavaScript dependency and the source and never seen that domain before. And it was like
a tenant based JavaScript file. So like you could customize your JavaScript for your tenant on that
third party SaaS product. And it was being added to this. So if somebody compromised that, you've now
added the single point of failure. It's crazy. Yeah. It's so interesting.
Especially on these bigger, hardened programs. This is something that I've talked a little bit
about post a live hacking event that happened in the past year with some of the guys afterwards.
It was just kind of discussing like when you've got these big targets that pay for impact that are very,
very secure and locked down. Many times the weakest link is going to be these third party endpoints
that they, or these third party providers that they pull in without doing too much of a security
assessment on it because they may have very solid security controls from just like you were talking
about before the episode with Donut and trying to build an authorization framework that just makes
it impossible at compile time to do an authorization issue. They may have protocols like that in place
at their organization. But when the freaking marketing team says, I need this plugin or whatever for my front
end, they're not going to audit that whole source code base, you know? And yeah. And they can't
continuously audit it either. Right. Maybe they audit it once and then in a year or two, you know,
they never get to see what happens and the vuln gets accidentally snuck in there or committed by accident.
And yeah, you know, it's such a risk. It's a huge risk. And then, and then, you know, like you guys were
saying as well, all of the whole internet is built on these like maintainer building blocks.
It's depressing to see, to be honest. And it makes you wonder.
Oh, is it open source awesome?
Yeah. There needs to be like some massive government grant or something like that for open source,
you know, maintainers that are just like, please continue doing the thing you're doing so that we
don't lose our whole internet infrastructure. That would be big.
Yeah. It really is.
Yeah. So yeah, I think it makes a lot of sense why you would target Next.js and that, that,
um, that target or that, uh, IPX piece of, of how you were able to, to cache that pretty rad.
The other vulnerability that I was looking at in here that seemed pretty interesting to me
was the open redirect via underscore next slash image. I mean, and just to be clear for anybody listening
to these, these vulnerabilities are long, long patch. You know, if they're running,
I don't know, something super old and it's not hosted, then maybe you'll still find these, but
um, these are long patch. So it's mostly just useful for the methodology. Um, and having, man, having an
open redirect on any website that has underscore next, you know, would be so clutch because it's so
helpful to have these. And, um, when you're looking for open redirects, I see the payload here was
slash backslash, slash backslash slash, right? So there's slashes in between and essentially what's
happening here or backslashes in between is it's getting normalized to a slash slash redirect, right?
Or a slash payload. And that's why it's redirecting, correct?
Do you have any other cool tricks like that you look for when you're doing, um, open redirect
searching? Um, there's so many and they're so dependent on the actual like implementation.
Uh, honestly, sitting there and like my tips and tricks, like, I don't know.
This is right. Sam, this is why podcasting is tricky, right? Because I said what I said earlier
about intuition, you know, and I said, I'm not a bunch of intuitive hunter, but that's more,
more so from a, from a top level, you know, architecture perspective. When you're trying
to explain why on a podcast, why you test the things you test it, or what is your methodology?
It's so hard when you don't have your hands on something. Like if you were just, if you had,
if I handed you a, you know, closed redirect and I said, Sam, make this an open redirect.
Uh, you know, I'm sure you would be able to talk through the concepts of what you're doing as
you're fiddling with it. But when I say, Sam, what's your methodology for open redirects?
It's real tricky, right? Right. Yeah, exactly. It's kind of funny,
like trying to come up with like condensed, like the knowledge into like a, you know,
a sense or whatever. So be a podcast thing that's like informative. Um, I totally agree.
Like searching for this in particular was fun because like the goal for me was like, well,
it essentially was allowing local images like explicitly. So like, for instance, if you wanted to proxy
underscore next slash IMG question mark image equals splash image.png, totally fine. Loves it.
It says, well, we're going to try to find an image. And if we can, we're going to proxy it for you and
serve it. Right. And for me, that's kind of interesting because it's like, well, I know that
slash slash will route to an internal, like a, uh, external domain and, uh, or like a full
qualified domain name. Yeah. So I was trying to play with that for a while. Then what I realized is that I was like,
well, it doesn't like, uh, two slashes in a row. So like I could do like forward slash backslash,
and then to make it finished, you can do a forward slash backslash again, and then you've got the FQDN.
Right. And then, uh, what I realized after that too, was that I think if you ended the URL in a
path that was not completed, or if I look back through it really quick, um,
yeah, if you, if you ended it in a slash, so next JS has this behavior, which is really funny.
The reason this one really exists is because, uh, in next JS, if you hit and a full, if you,
if you hit a path and the path doesn't exist, that ends in a slash. For instance, if you hit
slash test slash, and that's not a real thing, what it tries to do is take you back to slash test to see if
the real thing without the slash. Yeah. So what's cool about that though, is that at the time of
reporting it, the, the underscore next, uh, slash IMG would actually send an HR request to itself.
And then you could abuse that functionality because it would return the redirect to the user.
So then basically you would get, uh, open redirect for any site because it would try to send that
request to itself. And then it would serve the response that it got from itself, which had the
forward slash backslash forward slash backslash attacker.com.
Wow. So it was, it was creating, you were sort of creating a loop of sorts there.
Exactly.
Very cool, dude. Yeah. It's, it, it's tricky to explain all of those different, uh, open redirect
pieces, but one thing that's consistent with that is like, you have to have a very solid understanding of
browser redirect mechanics and URLs and how URLs are parsed in order to find all these. And then you just
got to try to figure out the places where, oh, the developer didn't consider the, you know, double
slash, uh, being a, a, a, a top level, you know, redirect, um, versus in a, um, a relative. So an
absolute redirect versus a relative redirect. Um, and so, yeah, no, I really, I really like this one and
man, I wish this still existed because what a gadget, what a gadget that would be, man, on so many websites.
Yeah. And that's interesting. Yeah. Well, I was going to ask, like, did you approach it at all
from like the static, you know, or like the, just because you have like the JS right in front of you.
So it's, but it wasn't just easier to test it sort of black box than it was to dig through a bunch of
JavaScript code and figure out how that works. Yeah. Luckily for me, I'm, I'm a very non source
good person. I'll do fine with source code and I enjoy it and I appreciate it.
But for me, uh, I like to just test the actual functionality versus trying to dig into the code.
Because one thing that my philosophy a little bit is when the developers wrote that code,
they wrote what they intended and wanted it to do. And even though if you know the tricks around
it, sometimes you'll trick yourself into thinking that something's working intended.
And if you take the approach of like an external person who's like, well,
I don't think it's working as intended. We'll try to figure it out. Then sometimes you can get better
results, but it's cool to work with Shubs because Shubs is a fantastic like source code auditor.
So we kind of merged a little bit where I was like smashing the keyboard and he's like analyzing
stuff in the source. And you can, you can bounce off of each other too, where you say, Hey, I'm
seeing something weird, a dynamic analysis, go figure out why that's happening. And then, you know,
they go figure out why that's happening. And it leads you to a clear picture of like, okay,
that's why that's happening. And you can exploit it further because you now have introspection into
the code surrounding the fringe weird functionality. I like that. I like that. All right, man, we are
two hours and 20 minutes in right now. So, um, let's go ahead and, and wrap up. The last thing that I
wanted to talk about here was you mentioned before that you have, um, a lot of success with dev versus
prod, um, in the context of JWTs being used as a form of, of, um, of authentication. Can you talk
a little bit about that? And maybe, I don't know if you have a story about it, but you can feel free
to share a story if you do. Yeah, sure. So, uh, the dev versus prod thing is really fun because, uh,
if you're a developer and you're writing like a next JS application and you have like, you know,
if I'm a startup and I start a company and I use next JS and I do all the things correctly,
but let's say I accidentally reuse the same key and I store it in my source code and then I deploy
a dev site and a prod site and I'm provisioning user IDs for each registered user. If I register
in dev, I'll be user ID three or whatever, but in prod I'm like, he's ready for 63. But a lot of
times what I could do is just copy over the dev JWT to prod and then I could access account number three.
And then like some funny stories too with that. Um, it's just kind of part of my
attack methodology now for like next JS websites, because it's just one of those things I
saw like a few times. Yeah. I think specifically for next JS because, uh, honestly with next JS,
it's getting a lot harder to test for bugs. I feel like, because like you've got everything in the
JavaScript and like, I don't know, it's all there, but like it just gets boring. It's the same thing
over and over again. So it's just not like entertaining to hack on. So I kind of, I've been
trying to do this for next JS websites because I know it's a common thing I've seen. Um, but yeah,
copying the staging JWT to prod and then seeing if there's an indifference for which account you get,
if the secret is the same. And you find that there's normally one piece of information they're
basing their author off of there, like, like an ID versus like an email or anything like that.
Yeah. A lot of times, a lot of times it's ID, but other times it's email. The ID ones are sometimes
harder to exploit because it's like UID based and then you can't really do anything unless you can control
it. But the ones that are fun are the email ones that don't like require confirmation.
Um, cause say you register like admin at company.com and like you do them one and the other and the
other one's not registered then yeah, you generate it. Just target whatever account you want and then
just opt into it. That's pretty cool. Exactly. Yeah. And it's, yeah, it's been a
vuln for a long time or like kind of a vuln class, but I've seen it kind of pop back up a tiny bit.
I think, I think Irby, Irby also mentioned that this is a part of his function or normal
methodology for this sort of thing. And I know he's popped some cool bugs with that in the past.
Um, so there's definitely, there's definitely bugs to be found in that, in that, uh, area. And I'm,
I'm kind of wondering as well, what your, what your recon looks like then, because you do have this whole
thing where you're like, where you're going deep for sure, but you're also finding the fringe assets
you need to find to get the impact. So to what degree do you spend time on, on recon versus
focusing on hacking applications you've discovered? Yeah. So recon, like I love recon for getting an
understanding and feel of the app. For instance, finding like, you know, dev.ant.company.com
versus prod or, and like kind of understanding the infrastructure. Um, I'm not a really big fringe
asset hunter. So I'm not really somebody who goes at like, you know, some crazy subdomain that popped up
for four seconds on cert.sh, right? Like I can't do that. It's not my style. Um, but what I'll do
is I'll use recon data to kind of get an understanding like whether or not there's Akamai hosts for
everything. And one of them is a non-Akamai host and I can change the host header and do, you know,
like that's how you get info. But, um, what I'll do for targeting assets is like, try to pull together
and understanding, like maybe there's a domain that has like a swagger file, maybe there's a domain that has
this and then I'll try to use it to attack whatever has the most functionality, whether that's dub dub dub
my account dot app dot, mostly those core ones I try to stick to. Dude, that's one of the most balanced
approaches I've, I've heard of. It takes on the pod is like use recon data to the extent that it gives
you a picture of the organization and to explain the full architecture of the organization. And then
from there you attack the thing that has the most features and the most attractive features as well.
Yeah. Very, very.
Right. Yeah. I love that because it's, yeah. There's another, yeah, there's a hacker, uh,
Cash Money Tanner. Tanner. He, uh, he has a similar attacking style of like Jack Cable,
maybe even Irby, but they're all like swear to the fact they're like manual hackers who
they'll employ stuff. Like they'll script stuff. Definitely. Like I've seen Tanner script like crazy
stuff and he's done really well, but like mostly they seem like they're manual testers where it's like,
it's like, why wouldn't you go after the part of the app with the most functionality?
Like if I could, some random assets can have two API calls that are like integers and not versus the
main app is like six years of like 400 developers rotating in and out of being fired or new ones.
Yeah. You know what I mean?
A hundred percent dude. Wow. That's a, that's a great way to wrap off this pod is, is that,
that really balanced approach to recon and, in looking at an organization holistically rather than
a individual web app. Um, that's, that's definitely something for me to chew on.
Joel, did you have anything else you wanted to toss out there before we bounce?
Um, no, I mean, I'll, I'll open it up to Sam because, um, you know, I know we've talked about
a bunch of different things, but you know, obviously hack compute and some of the other stuff you're
working on your blog, um, where can people find you and, uh, and watch out for more of your awesome
research? Yeah. Uh, I think samcurry.net and then, uh, hackcompute.com. Uh, yeah, I'm trying to
continue to publish like cool web stuff to samcurry.net, but I haven't done too, I've been
doing a lot more. So I'm kind of happy to be able to publish some more stuff. But, uh, besides that,
like hackcompute.com, I want to publish more apps like stuff. Um, yeah, mostly thank you to
Dustin and Joel for putting this together. Like, I don't know if to the listener, like behind the
scenes, there's so much effort. Like there's a full Google doc of like 10 hours of like writing
out, like, and then researching and figuring stuff out. Yeah. So it's a total honor. Um, really,
really appreciate them. So that's it. Well, thanks for coming on, Sam. We'd love to have you on and,
uh, we'll definitely have you back on in the future to share some of this cool research that's coming
off at, uh, at samcurry.net. So, all right. That's the pod. Cheers. Peace. Peace. Peace.